18 year old and shit like that.
Right.
His daughter.
Here we go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Three,
two,
one.
Damn.
It's been a minute since we
did one of these hot minute.
How long has it been?
I can't remember his months.
Longer than that.
The cows just not part of the fight.
This,
the fight companion.
These,
wow.
You're kicking them out.
I can't believe I knew
it was going to happen.
Dude.
Why are we going to do,
we got to fall in,
kind of get to put them out to see,
man,
he's,
he had an old,
he just can't make it a sentence.
She had the Beatles that they kicked out.
Jamie says name.
We're radio came in the original drummer.
He was a drummer.
Right.
Well Fuck Peter.
If you bring in rain,
go.
He was,
uh,
it was,
it was so sad.
Pete.
Best.
Yeah.
I was listening to this
Malcolm Gladwell book on tape.
It's called outliers and they got
into a part about the Beatles,
the Beatles,
man,
when this Pete Pete passed,
he was there in the beginning.
Man,
he,
he did these crazy gigs with them.
Could you imagine like you being a part
of a band and then you get kicked out of
that band?
It turns into the Beatles.
That's never happened before.
I mean,
no one is ever those before.
Right,
so no one has ever been.
Is that him right there.
Oh,
he doesn't look like he fits in,
does he?
How bout when has it ever been that guy?
I bet he went home was like,
but they screaming when they first,
Oh my God.
There was nothing like that before that.
That's a piece.
People,
people say that that was all staged.
No,
come on ad screaming.
No saying that
beavers are faking to,
I'll send you a link.
The Biebs has the same effect on some men.
Girls lose nobody.
Mine.
Certain dudes,
Brendan Jabber like that.
Never like if you look at that old,
those go crazy.
That footage,
those chicks,
dude,
that's he as they didn't
have the internet,
they didn't know there'd be endorsed.
That was natural.
That's how every girl naturally feels.
There's no Instagram,
no Instagram.
There's nothing.
So first time you see
them in person we have,
is there a possibility that it was set up?
Is there a possible put
the conspiracy we have,
we have a,
an idea of what women are based on,
how women behave around us when they're
worried about the way we think about
them.
The same way we behave
differently when it's all us,
when there's no women around,
there's just ways that people behave.
And if you leave all these women together,
hold on a second,
right?
If you leave all of these women
together and it's 19 what,
what year was that?
Said?
What's that?
The sixties late sixties right?
Ones
do,
they didn't even barely
have books back then.
I mean there was the kitchen,
he a Beatles girl screaming.
Of course they had books.
I'm joking,
but what I'm not joking around about
it is that they had no one had ever
experienced anything like that before.
And if you get all these girls together
and they're seeing these guys who
they're seeing on television and they're
seeing on the Ed Sullivan and there's,
they're seeing him everywhere and they're
sitting there in the newspapers and
the magazines and they see these guys
and the sounds they make are so good in
the way they sing and play music
together is so magical and it's so
unprecedented and it's a new kind
of sound and they just special,
you know,
these girls just can't help it.
Like me,
Brian,
you know when you're a pig,
you ever see a taping of a TV show?
Did you ever see the big
applause light with our plots?
And they make,
is that a real plaza?
Is that a fake applause?
I mean that's fake.
Their conditional.
Well that's a different level level to
listen those uplights
they're not a conspiracy.
They're not a conspiracy,
but they are kind of cheesy dude,
look at Justin Bieber's concert.
I mean listen,
I worked at hot as fuck.
He is hot,
but I worked.
So I worked in security for it,
like some of these uh,
bands and I worked for the hip
when Hilary Duff was in her a day,
I'm talking bitches passing
out from excitement at the,
grabbed their big asses out of the crowd.
That's not fake.
That's real dude.
It's fucking bitches crying.
I have to understand that girls have
a completely different reaction.
Not all girls,
but some,
some dude's too,
or you brought up.
Do you remember the reactions?
There's a,
there's a lot of Beatles
footage of the audience,
but there's girls just
fucking flipping out,
screaming and crying,
like just going nuts.
You remember those toe shots?
100% look,
do,
do I think that girls would act up to
get on camera to make it a bigger deal?
Yes.
Do I think that's what
they were all doing?
No.
Look at this mayhem dude.
I think they couldn't believe that the
Beatles were actually there and there'd
never been anybody like the
Beatles before hock thirsty bro.
I think they were just hypnotized.
There's something singing out in their
DNA about that music because look,
we can listen to the Beales
today and it's still great.
I listened to the white
album just the other day.
It was amazing.
How was it?
That's a different beginning
to where sexy though.
They weren't like heart drops their
dick had here because don't have to take
basic did don't know.
It's the music.
They're so good.
And this,
this movie or this book rather.
The Malcolm Gladwell was
all about extraordinary
performances like what people
have done that's been
completely extraordinary.
And one of them was talking about how
the Beatles got so good because they
played,
I think it was Berlin was where
they play or Homburg one of those.
So they played somewhere
where they played all night.
They played like multiple hours a
night and they played every day.
They played an insane number of shunt
of audience in front of audiences.
They just played constantly and he
talked about the importance of that,
that by the time we got to see them,
by the time they were on television,
they had played together so many more
times than the average band where we'll do
in their entire career.
Like the
sheer numbers.
They were always playing,
always doing these live performances.
I forget where it was,
but the cavern club where,
where was it?
Beatles at the cavern club
is what it was called,
I think.
Where is the place that they
performed early in their career?
I want to say it's a Homburg.
This says the first of a long series
of resident nights during a traditional
jazz evening,
they performed an interval as the only
rock group during an all night session
including jazz.
Maybe it might be one of
many things they've done.
I would not think this
was before they made it.
This was like as they were
like young guys coming up,
just think about the
Beatles in Hamburg corner.
Just so many repetitions.
Yeah,
and he talked about how it,
and then think about that
Pete best dude go fuck.
I was in the mix.
What would it do?
What did he end up donating thing?
He start his own band.
How do you recover from that biggest l?
Here's the thing,
there's never been a Beatles before,
so we're looking at the
Beatles like we already know.
They're awesome.
They're all already a part
of pop culture history.
I miss them.
I'm younger.
Yeah,
but if we live back then,
man,
if it was like 1963 in the
Beatles burst in the scene,
you would be like,
why is there anything close to that now?
There were two.
We have too much stimulus.
We see it too much.
Instagram.
We get inside their lives.
It's hard.
It's hard to find some huge bank.
There's that Korean ban that's fucking,
Ooh,
a Korean bands freak out of
k pop and I forget the name,
but they're starting to,
uh,
you'll see the,
the put them in like at the
grammys and stuff and the,
the entire crowd is these young teenage
Korean girls going fucking ape shit
flow.
They're huge.
But there's like the
backstreet boys and new kids.
What about the metal?
Have you heard of them?
What?
Baby metal?
No,
you haven't heard a baby metal?
Never Bro.
You've heard of baby metal does Amy's on
the ball with the always spirit to the
baby.
Metal is super technical power metal,
but they have little
Japanese girl singing.
It's gigantic.
It's like God gigantic he or patient.
No,
it's just funny you can't
put this on youtube right?
We'll Yank.
Damn.
It's super hardcore metal.
This is like,
it's like a
Gotcha.
We talked about repetitions.
They do.
You know in Korea there you can watch a
documentary on the k pop stuff and they,
they don't like,
it's not chemistry where the GIM together,
they forced them together and then they,
it's,
you're talking 14 hours a day.
They make them rehearse,
practice,
practice kept.
They can't have girlfriends,
boyfriends to tell him when to eat,
where to sleep.
It's a bs fog to that noise.
That's why I said I'd like the,
one of the biggest,
uh,
Korean pop singers often commit suicide.
Just couldn't,
didn't want to deal with the,
with the restrictions and the control
and sounds like Illuminati cheesy Christ.
Well,
so they're like,
oh,
the old school studio model.
Yeah.
You don't remember that.
You ever hear that?
No.
With um,
they didn't,
they used to do that with
these two that with bands,
they do that with a,
even with movies,
it's signed in the old school studio days.
It's signed on to these long term
contracts and they would produce all this
stuff for them and forced them to
do things and studios would sign the
contracts.
Right.
Are they still do that?
That's them by the way.
Jamie bts bts behind the scenes.
That was things were,
it was crazy.
We haven't said anything about the files.
I don't know.
I don't know anything about
what young kids are doing today.
Every,
I have to go to Jamie and Jamie's in
intermediary because he's a grown man.
He's not,
he's not a bulldozer.
Bluebells 20 or 35 I have to try to
pay attention or the say I tried to,
man,
he's Jamie struggling to pay
attention that the young girls,
you know,
other mall multilayered my son,
young girls with the cutoff Jean shorts
in the ass cheeks hanging out the back.
That's,
I know that's in his crazy
ass out the back of the back.
People just trying so hard
just to get recognition,
man.
Ah,
it's a fascinating time to be a person.
It really is so interesting right now.
It's a good time.
Oh yeah.
It's a great time.
Also a rough time.
Wow.
It's all the mass shooters and that stuff.
That's funny.
Top part,
especially in charge or thousand oaks.
How was a safe ass place?
Yeah.
How does that number ring?
A former marine who was in the Las Vegas
shooting as a survivor was the survivor
and the thousand oaks shooting the fucking
insane.
Think about the odds of that.
That's why I was told when I grow,
think about,
well I think there,
there was,
so who was in the Vegas shooting?
Who survived that?
Who's at this one that died,
right.
It was that,
I think so.
Either way.
It's dark shit.
They don't have no idea
what his motive or anything.
Right.
The cops,
it investigated them.
They investigated them,
um,
fairly recently because they thought
he was unstable or something like that.
I think his mom called the cops,
like some,
somebody called the cops
and they investigated him,
talked to him.
And that's always tough if you're f
guys like what do you want us to do?
Arrest them for being fucking weird.
Like he didn't exactly like what can
we do for every one that does this cat
trail,
the guy thousand that don't,
you know,
I mean you've got to figure out what the
fuck is it that allows people to decide
to hit that switch.
Like I don't know if they understand that,
like the what is,
what's the psychological
motivation of that?
But it's gotta be a sign that there's
something wrong with our culture.
If it's kept popping up so often and
he's gotta be a sign that something,
there's something wrong.
Obviously they always chalk it up
to mental health and all right.
Yeah,
he was 100 percenters.
You know how many people
have mental health issues
and none of them are going to
blow people up or two people,
different kinds of mental health issues.
But then there's also just bad people.
Yeah.
Sometimes you got to
chalk it up to that too.
That's true too,
but you know a lot of bad people,
like a giant number.
I've had horrible things happen.
Yeah.
That's where it gets
weird because it's like,
okay,
what made
this guy become who he is and it's,
you definitely should.
You definitely should arrest
someone who does evil shit.
Right?
But what makes a person get to a
point where they can do evil shit?
This is a whole series of
events probably take place,
including abuse,
physical abuse,
maybe sexual abuse.
Sometimes there's not.
Sometimes you just get a bad apple.
Like with Jeffrey Dahmer,
it was like his pants liked it.
Yeah.
I mean you definitely need to get
into some weird shit with his mom,
but still,
you know how some people are born,
they have problems with their liver?
Yeah.
Some people are born,
they have problems with their brain.
That's just a fact.
We know that there's
problems with the eyesight.
This problems with,
you know,
people are born deaf.
Yup.
There's errors in the human body.
Sometimes you don't think that someone
can be born to just completely squirrely,
wired wrong.
Of course they can.
Sociopathy makes sense.
I'm not a doctor,
obviously a fucking moron,
but I bet a doctor would agree that
when you're dealing with mental health
issues you probably dealing with
this giant spectrum of them.
What if there's something we could check
so that like when they're a baby could
check and aside DNA called eugenics but
in there like this he's going to be a
bad kid.
Do we just do it?
But how you always going
to be about and why,
how many people on the
cemetery of your face,
how could,
how many people want to be a better
person and they don't ever get it together
and how many people are lacking like
some sort of coaching or lacking some
inspiration,
positive people in their life and then
their life spirals further and further
downhill.
How many people are on the border?
God,
the majority,
right?
Yes.
Cause I think people change and I think
people improve as they grow older and as
they become wiser and they
have more experiences.
But also if you,
if you look at the mass shooters,
a lot of them are quote unquote losers.
They live in their,
the parents' basement
and everything going on.
A lot of them were white
look like shit use mode.
They're always white and they,
oh,
he's white,
low energy,
always white and low energy,
low energy.
This guy didn't seem low energy.
You know,
the Nazis made propaganda films.
Uh,
basically,
um,
uh,
they made people believe that a mentally
deranged people were out on the streets
attacking and killing people and they
may propaganda film so that they would
okay killing someone who was,
you know,
mentally deranged.
You always have to be careful of people
trying to label someone as someone that
you don't have to consider
it a regular human.
Someone who you could disregard.
That's what they do with the juice.
Right.
That's like the rats are stealing from us.
They're monsters.
That's what they do.
People done that throughout
history to other people.
There's like a scientific term for it.
I don't remember what it is,
but genics damn,
I was telling no,
that's not what I'm saying.
That's a scientific term for people
that demonize other groups of people and
their,
the way they look at propagandists.
No,
no.
The way you look at people like this is
a person and you looked at the enemy,
you would look at them like a subhuman.
There's,
it's like there's a psychological,
it is definitely racist.
Yeah.
But there's like a trait that people like.
There's like a pattern that
people commonly fall into
with that humanize them.
The enemy.
We're all stupid in it.
We are all stupid,
but dehumanizing the enemy.
It's a natural thing that people do.
It just fucking everyone does it.
It's so weird.
And it's how people can do gang warfare
is how people can do tribal warfare.
It's how people can do inter
continental w where you had your boy,
what's the name of the English cat?
The hypnotizer.
Daymond Aaron Brown hair and Brown.
Yeah.
Have you seen his thing on Netflix?
No.
It's fucking sick.
And so I'm not,
no spoiler,
but so he,
he took a guy,
like he took a ton of people,
took a guy who lives in Florida who's in
construction and who was super kind of
racist towards immigrants like
Mexicans and Hispanics and uh,
he sat him down.
He's got,
he's the perfect one for sure.
Cause your phone off Bro.
Damn it.
What in the fuck God damn Bro.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hey G.
Oh,
I'm on a bike companion
right now with Joe Rogan.
Say Hey.
Hey.
Okay.
Sorry about that.
Did you hear about it or what?
Yeah,
yeah,
I was watching it as a,
um,
I watched your fight with Rosenthal.
Um,
oh,
I of them.
Yup.
Points dude.
That's the point system.
You know what I mean?
That's the way they go down.
They call me
and then they took it away from him.
Match.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well I was smashing where I
had the under hook on him.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
Hello?
I'm on call.
I come back out to quarter guard and then,
and then they call me
for calling him like,
like,
like I don't get that when we
pass on our knees all the time.
Like you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So that's what it was.
They called you,
they called stalling for
you being in top half.
Yeah.
Is that why you lost?
Oh,
I thought I thought it was the judge's
decision and they gave it to him based on
that.
Okay.
This is super technical.
The only thing I mentioned I
talk about to the call you guys,
it's tough.
All right.
I don't think Jiu Jitsu is
boring but I don't either.
But if you could explain it.
No fucking idea what John Martinez in the
house monster Joe is a fantastic tool.
I tell dude under Eddie Bravo and he's
one we referenced many times in the
podcast,
him and his brother Richie boogeyman
because both those guys started out as
bboys.
They started out as these Israeli last
break dancers and they have incredible
control of their body.
And I remember when they first
started training at Eddie's plays.
Eddie was like,
like,
like he had a new form yet.
He's like,
dude,
fuck you break everyone.
Practice
practicing.
And he wrestled.
So he's got both.
But what's up with what's
going on with Tony?
I feel bad for him.
I feel like they're leaving
him in the fucking done.
No,
no,
no.
They're leaving him.
No,
no,
no.
Hey No,
they,
they're very serious about
doing something with Tony.
First we'll talk about,
Dana even said that he is most likely
next to next in line for Khabib.
Tony Ferguson.
Look after you to perform that man.
Fuck yeah,
he does.
And after that performance against Pedis,
like come on man.
This is,
this is the time.
It's the time to set him right.
He's so fucking tough.
He wants it too though.
I think could be said him or GSP,
right man.
Tony hasn't lost in,
what is it?
12 fights now?
How many fights is it?
1111 straight.
Well,
fight win streak against
guys like Edson Barboza,
Darcy's,
Kevin Lee,
Kevin Leach triangles,
him pedis.
Pedis gets an injury,
but because Thompson,
Josh Thompson
on hose up,
Lando Bernados,
Lando fuck beat tough fucking guys,
man.
Lando came at him.
He had no training camp for that one.
She was training for that one.
Well land they make though.
Lando is a talented guy,
man.
He pushed him.
I mean he clipped him and
he clipped him with that.
He does this a head kick out of the break.
Um,
but he survived that in one.
I mean,
dude,
Tony Ferguson is a fucking beast.
Look at those three Ho steel.
Those are no pumps,
man.
Josh Thomson,
Monster Barboza Ranada just to
look us and Joe's bows of an Datta.
Hofeld dos Anjos and Kevin Lee and then
Anthony Pettis in a row we can pass.
Those guys does not nearly get
nearly get the attention he deserves.
God Man,
he's got a million
followers now and he's more,
he should,
he should.
He should be.
First of all,
I don't think he should have been stripped
because he got injured one time doing
USC prep and doing something
and he tripped over some wires.
It's a freak accident.
It just something that happened,
you know,
to strip them because of that.
Like,
I don't know.
I think he'd be,
Anthony Pettis has 60% we know already,
but,
uh,
he,
he's looked better before
the injury obviously,
but him coming back that fast doing what
he did is it's like even adopt cruise.
Like,
I don't know how the fuck he's doing this.
So I thought even as good as he looked,
that's not even him at his,
you know,
he's gonna be even better
than this next fight.
Well,
I think more pet has look really good too.
You got to give credit to Pedis for sure.
Clip Titus,
collect him and he had him hurt,
but Tony figured out a way
to hold on and survive.
But he didn't look like he
was missing a beat to me.
He looked,
he looked very in tune.
Did I?
I heard something that
he didn't spar for this.
Is that true?
Um,
I'm not too sure what he
does with the striking.
I'm never there when he
transferred the striking.
I have no idea to tell you the truth.
You don't stay all can't.
We just deal with the ground
now when we do no shit told me.
And I've heard that too when he spars,
when we do Jujitsu we uh,
we definitely spark situation situation.
No like straight up striking.
No 16 ounce gloves.
Man Data is such a debate.
What a crazy debate that is.
Does the same thing,
does he know sparring?
Here's his starting six years might not,
that might not be a bad idea.
Robbie Lawler took six
years off sparring too.
He did.
But then he became better when he went
to [inaudible] eight t when you went to
ATC and started a training with some
serious talent down there and dropped down
to one 70.
I would like to know that,
that the period of no sparring,
I think that was the 85
period when he was at strike.
Well Chad,
Chad Mendez took a while off too cause
obviously he got busted but then he took
time off and then he's
looking frickin pretty gnarly.
Yeah,
Dude.
Um,
and haven't Dale Earnhardt junior on the
other day and talking to him about the,
the brain injuries that he
sustained from driving his car.
And I haven't heard.
Yeah,
horrible dude.
He got to,
couldn't walk across the room.
He had a hold on the tables and shit.
I was,
as he was walking me.
Did he say he's head concussion?
Does he know what's in it?
Something insane like 12
over a period of four years.
Holy Shit,
that's a lot.
I want to say it was something like 12
concussions over a period of 40 how's he
know?
He's great.
Super Nice Guy.
Very,
very genuine guy.
He said that the length popping up
says at least 20 fuck concussions.
It's more than some fighters.
God Damn it.
That's crazy.
That is so crazy.
But you know he's a lot,
a lot of like serious problems
that he had worked through,
but he found a good doctor that has
as good cognitive therapy really.
So he's had some kind
of side effects from it.
He had a bunch of side effects,
but they cleared them up
through these exercises.
Really interesting stuff like,
and he was basically,
I made the analogy that it's like,
is it like exercising your mind?
Like is just like exercising your body.
Like there's things you can do that
make things grow and make it an yeah and
make things strong.
Hurts CBD oil and fish oil if really
the exports that I know who are in that
field and with the brain always
tell me a tons of Fisher on CBD oil.
Krill oil too.
That stuff's real good.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Stuff.
Anything that reduces inflammation but um,
that damn Taylor and her thought crazy.
These guys decide that's that.
Some of them decide,
you know,
cowboy was doing that for
awhile and probably still is.
I don't know what he was doing,
what he's doing now.
I didn't talk to him about this.
CanNot sparring heavy.
It wasn't sparring at all.
He's just hitting pads.
Just hitting pads.
It's not that I know.
I ain't the horse idea man.
Boxers beg to differ.
You talked to any of those
boxers and they're like,
no,
I think it was a Loma
Chenko and a while to go.
We like to get a 12 rounds in
hard right before the fight,
like two weeks,
three weeks out and then we cut
it off like three weeks out.
Just make,
see where we're at and
cutting about boxing though
is your hands are wrapped up.
You know your,
your gloves are on,
they've got,
you've got 16 ounce training gloves
or maybe even 20 if you're a beast,
right?
You've got big ass puppy 16 you got big
ass puffy gloves and there's no kicking.
The thing about like kicking it,
like to see,
I bought Sam's book,
I'd feel like boxing is more dangerous.
It is in a way that all they're doing is
head hunting all it's all head and it's
just head.
Right?
But especially at that level.
Well,
you're not getting kicked.
I know,
but in in like high level,
Jim's like black house or
a t t a k people there,
they're not really going to throw
those kicks as hard as they can.
Man.
I don't know about all the Shit
fucking old school shoot box.
There's a lot of,
gosh,
they're still going after it like that.
There's a lot of guys that will still
talk to you about the benefits of going
after it.
Like that.
Yeah.
Out for Rasa.
Hobby was sandy gets guys who
try to kill George Saint Pierre.
He give him extra money if you can knock
them out just because he's so good.
No doing shit.
He's so good.
They're not doing it to
she names nightmare card.
He wants to be in danger for us wants
Georgian and danger in legitimate danger.
So his in his mind is you put George in
legitimate danger all the time in the
gym and he figures out a way to get
through that and he gets comfortable with
that so that when it comes to the fight,
it's the same thing.
That's easy to say if you and
George St and I love for us,
but when you have George St Pierre who's
the smartest dude to ever run of the
full marks guys ever fight
and he's so technical,
you whoever you're
going to bring in there,
you're not going to hit Joe.
Let me ask you this.
He's so maybe,
maybe there's benefit and
not when you're early going,
when you're learning technique more
and you're really learning timing and
pacing.
Maybe then is when you should spar,
like way more technical.
But then when you get
older and you're better,
like maybe you need the fear of an actual
fight and then then you can just slide
right into the fight.
Smart cause you're now also
cause your head movements better.
Your mood.
Yeah.
Smarter,
protect yourself more.
But the danger is still a hundred percent
real so that we're aware of all the
day.
Yep.
So that way when you're in a fight,
it feels exactly like your training.
It's not a bad idea.
Useful,
but you're already there.
You're already at a high
level of proficiency.
You already have the tools.
Did I really think that there's an a
real issue with fighters and this is a
impossible to tell after it's over
right after the career's over.
Like what,
why did they do it this way?
What if they had done it that way?
Maybe it would've worked better.
Well,
you know,
Chuck Liddell,
um,
is he's not with Hackleman
for this TRTs fight.
He just shot that like was an
old school type of training.
So I decided to go somewhere else.
I was training with Einstein.
Izzy.
Well listen,
I'm a big fan of uh,
Einstein as a Jujitsu.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
And strength and
conditioning costs on about,
yeah,
he knows a lot about slow movement,
slow movement lifting,
you know,
slowly like he's a,
what does he call it?
What does,
I don't know what the style is.
It's all super slow.
That's what it is.
Right.
This is working with Antonio Mckee.
Mckee was he like working with him?
Um,
but uh,
I've known that dude forever.
How long have you known that dude?
He was in King of the cage when I
used to commentate back in 2000.
And he's a damn good
fighter for a long time.
Right.
His son is awesome.
The Antenna Mickey San Antonio Mckee,
Toro.
I was talking about Einstein.
He's,
oh my bed.
But no know.
But both of them,
chuck is training with uh,
what's a gym called?
Power garage or some shit like that.
Sure.
I forget,
but that's where Chuck's at.
Cause cause what I heard on the street
and I'll say I fucking love John
Hackleman.
Shout up John Hockman,
but it was such an old
school way of training.
He's like,
dude,
it's the to advance so fast.
I need to go somewhere.
Which workers saw that?
He goes down to Jay Glazer's
place to right the unbreakable.
I don't know if they're
in business together.
He's been there forever.
He's been one of the starters.
What?
How would a dope place Jay
Glazer put together a sunset?
It's amazing.
Have you been there chuck?
No Man.
I've never been,
but I've seen all these videos are
really con might displace is crazy.
Snoop Dogg's in there,
Wiz Khalifa,
sparring.
Somebody's Pete Denny was in
that were one of the jail.
You know I'm Wiz Khalifa?
Nope.
No.
Snoop Dogg rather sparred with a
legit sparred with Daniel Seraphin.
Snoop Dogg was Seraphin
wasn't hitting them.
He goes,
but let's look at this.
Snoop is in there and Seraphina just
kind of using head movement and kind of
touching them a little bit,
but you know how fucking
goddamn terrifying that must be.
Does this have gloves
on in front of Seraphim?
Do you think snoop knows?
Is he aware?
I don't think so.
He's got so probably told them was like,
hey man,
you know what the guy's done.
That guy might not be,
you know,
the best in the world.
He might not be the best world,
but he's a fucking monster.
Dude.
Come back to snoop.
He is built like shit leg.
He's so strong too black twizzler and he
cuts a Shitload of weight to that guy's
a gigantic what?
Wade is a seraphim fight.
I want to say fights at
85 but he's super jacked.
He's a thicket.
Damn straight steal.
Just a real dangerous dude.
So to see him in their
sparring with snoop dog,
I'm like,
I wonder if Snoop Dogg
understands that this is like,
it's like Paul and at a a
giant pit bull or something.
You know,
I wonder.
I don't think he know to what level.
I don't know.
I mean you're a Sikh.
You ever seen one that has got ball?
Snoop dog's got real balls.
Did Not just do that,
but to do that and put it up,
make a video of it and look true and dude.
And it didn't look like an asshole.
No,
it didn't look like an ass for a guide.
It's not a like a long time combat sport,
notable athletes,
you know what I mean?
He's not like some guy
we've known about like,
like if you saw,
um,
like there's,
there's some guys like Mario Lopez,
if you saw Mario Lopez box
and when somebody you'd go,
yeah,
that guy can box.
Everybody knows it.
Everybody.
He has smokers.
Like everybody knows Mario Lopez smokers.
Yeah.
He smoker gets a friend of mine.
I think Frank Gallo it.
Fuck him up.
But,
oh wow.
Dario.
I know he punched Acey Slade and I do,
I've seen,
I've trained with frank man.
He's feisty one.
Yeah,
I believe you.
I mean,
he looks tough,
but Lopez can fight.
I think,
you know.
Yeah.
I think you need is a
wildcard.
West for wafer carries himself.
This is one of the reasons why I think
he really knows how to box when I'm
around really arrogant way.
Not really arrogant,
but it's,
he's,
he knows how to fight.
He's a nice guy.
Do you remember our buddy?
Uh,
he was a porn star.
He was the one who,
uh,
who fought Mario Lopez,
goddammit Derek my out and his real name.
Oh Dude,
there's still porn.
Oh,
black guy.
Jared diamond.
It's not dark.
Dark Diamond Tyler night.
Tyler night.
Oh,
that's his porno name.
Totally lights weren't on there.
What a great.
And he's also an author and he,
um,
he runs like crazy
marathons and shit now too.
Doesn't he still dicking girls down?
It was just older,
I'm not sure.
So anyway,
he had an amateur fight.
He used to go to 10th planet.
Really Nice Guy.
And he had an amateur
fight with Mario Lopez.
He had one of them smokers.
Like how do you go day?
Mario dropped him,
I think ac Slater fuck the most and
Mara Matas either stopped him or he won,
um,
a decision,
but Tyler dropped him Tarla drop morrow.
So it was a real fight.
So it,
that to me like,
because Tyler was jacked,
he was like super powerful back then.
And I think that if he can come back
from getting dropped and still win,
you know,
he's Mario,
no shit too.
When it comes to box and I've done
a podcast on just about boxing.
I'm sure he knows his shit
when you guy really is a,
you know,
I mean,
I'd like to see him do something.
I've never seen him actually box somebody.
No,
me neither does any like 45 yeah.
So do you think it is everybody in here?
Yeah,
he looks beautiful.
He's got perfect.
I know what he's doing,
but it's working.
How old are you?
35 he looks younger than you do.
Mario Lopez don't have a
wrinkle on his pretty face.
Dude.
Ac Slater has an age,
whatever moisturizer he's got.
I want
Brian.
Dude,
I haven't watched one second.
This fight I ever needed.
Several fights there.
Well not there.
He looks like.
Feels like.
Say you get stung by all
the bs and the cheeks.
Then
Super Nice guy too.
Really,
really nice.
Joe Professional to hosting.
He's abused.
Who's blowing up faster than Leo?
Theo Vaughn feel Vaughn's killer.
He's out there.
He's,
it's a funny guy,
man.
He's a really funny guy.
That whole rat king at the strap thing.
You know that he's got going podcast.
He sits hysterical.
He's so funny.
He's a belt to all the shows.
You know,
it takes pictures with fans.
Peanut strap that funny.
They came in as a wrestler.
Well,
when we had wrapped port on,
he came in as like,
oh man,
he's crazy.
He's so funny.
He's hilarious and he's such a good guy.
Super happy to see dude,
when we did that,
a show in Phoenix with Ari.
Oh Yay.
Big Crazy show.
Ryan Theo.
Theo fricking destroyed,
destroyed.
It was so much.
We always destroys.
Every time I see him he's like,
um,
he's not just funny.
Right?
He's funny and you,
you like,
you don't know anybody like him.
I've never heard it.
He's so good.
His upbringing from New Orleans and
being in therapy since he was like seven.
He's such a unique dude,
man.
He's really,
really unique.
It's real good.
I'll tell you who else
I've never really hung out.
Was with a big J big.
Jay's a big chase.
Awesome.
He's hilarious.
He's a great guy.
All those legion of skanks guys,
those guys are the best.
I don't know any nice guys.
I just know it well.
I know big J now.
Do you know Louis?
I don't know metals.
Louis is great.
There's,
there's Gomez.
Um,
there's there just Dave Smith who's
I've had on my podcast of gang times.
If you ever wanted someone
to understand that,
that could understand politics
and actually be funny.
Oh yeah.
He's really good at that.
Yeah.
He's a libertarian.
He's one of those guys,
which usually means like a white
guy with a gun and no disrespect.
Only time I ever listened
to the show was when,
uh,
it was about the cause.
I think they had one of the dudes on
the show when Amy Schumer like rob the
stage.
Remember that New York I listened
to that cause big Jay was like,
kind of give me the benefit of the doubt.
But then the restaurant,
we're just roasting here.
This is the one time it's hilarious.
Yeah.
Uh,
was Ari on that one as well?
Yeah.
He goes super hard in the paint.
He does go hard and Ari's great man.
He's not here to play games.
He's great.
He didn't give a fuck Ari's,
he's an animal dude.
That motherfucker went from not working
out at all to doing this sober October
fitness challenge and getting,
you know,
like hundreds of points more than Tom
Ziglar and Bert Kreischer guys who work
out all the time.
Tom and per workout all the time.
All the time.
I mean burn off steam.
I mean Tom looks good,
but from where they're from,
but they're not like in shape.
I love bolts and bolt,
but bro,
it's all on where they're starting from.
I know,
I know.
Starting from a place where they
were both really overweight and they,
they talked themselves into
this weight loss challenge.
They lost all the weight.
Tom Kept it off.
Tom Looks amazing,
looks amazing and kind to,
I don't want bridge fluctuating.
It's been fun.
But Taiwan,
I'm skinny.
Manawan I'm healthy.
But is this the new rocky
movie commercials that what?
This house,
I'm going to go on forever.
I love it there.
Michael B.
Jordan do all the steroids.
He's jacked,
jacked.
He's creepy jacked.
He's like super athlete jacked.
He's so,
he's so good at like being a bad guy too.
He was great in that Black
Panther movie has a bad guy.
I can whatever.
I see Michael Jordan's name.
What do I see Michael [inaudible] joins
name I was thinking of crystal is tweet
goes the B and Michael B.
Jordan stands for basketball.
Crazy,
right?
I go back
whenever I see it stuck with me
to delete this so silly.
Oh Dude.
He's like one of the silliest guys ever.
He makes me laugh so hard,
man.
Man.
He's not just funny.
He's so silly.
Like that kind of shit.
The beast eds for basketball.
I do just that.
It's so
great.
It's so good.
But that he does that all the time.
Like is his Instagram feed
is all just him being silly.
Dude's like he's bored all day till it
gets on stage and he just does silly
shops shop.
Making fun of people walk into the
coffee shop to funny comic to Matt Deleon
makes me laugh harder than anyone.
Man.
He's a funny guy.
You know Larry,
but I think I love him on stage,
but I think I like him as much when
he does is a silly internet shit too.
Like when you see,
I don't know why he keeps going.
He keeps going out by him
while he goes out to everybody,
man.
Dude,
you see when he was in metabolism,
when he's entertaining
rapping like m and m.
Yes.
Oh my God.
And I told them cause meaning that me
and him love Worldstar hip hop and I made
it on there and then he made on it.
So I sent them the link.
I went,
Bro,
you've made it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm Worldstar hip hop world starred.
Yeah,
you got world started
because he's on there for a,
for something that's hilarious for this.
Just making it up as he gets
tossed to get an abortion.
Then the divorce thing,
time to hear with the forum,
the candidates doing this,
why are you panicking and you're looking
to stay on at mannequins and I'm going
on a fan of kids trying
to get up a planet.
Gifts,
complaining.
Constantin Capanpan
panic is Santa Cunanan.
I'm in a companion banner
chant and on a standup banner.
Well,
you don't got to stay on one
and get a link and a stamina.
Do you see the edit?
They did Jamie on m and m's
actual body with the video.
It's ridiculous.
Oh,
he can pull it off,
man.
He's so silly.
Yeah,
that's a good,
that's a good example.
Like we were talking about
the over guy who's just,
he's got his own uniquely
ridiculous kind of comedy.
Which some strange reason
when you talked to a,
or you talked to any of his
friends who've known him forever.
They're like,
no,
all he's wanting to do since he
was a kid has made people laugh.
This is lily what he's meant to do.
Yeah.
I guess just the filariasis silly dude.
Remember he's huge on
vine before it went away.
I mean,
you're talking,
he's one of the main stars on vine,
man for doing this type of stuff.
Makes Sense.
Meals,
that kind of shelves all day.
His Instagram's great.
Oh,
if I could post the
texts that he sends me.
I mean you get millions and
millions that they're so funny.
Man.
Like we comes off torn,
has all this money.
Then he had an,
he goes,
dude,
something's wrong with my
microwave and then hits the button.
Just all this cash faucet
cause I'm know hook to do.
We always send each other pictures
of our check rather reason.
Just talking.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
He's a funny dude.
How fun is it having friends
that are comedians the best,
the most fun to hang with the best.
Everybody's always being silly.
Everybody's always
putting you in your place.
Oh,
you out of your bullshit.
You're like,
oh no,
I love Chris because he
dresses like a fuck boy too.
So if I wear this jacket
to the comedy store,
everyone make fun of me,
but Chris at least be like,
come on,
stick up for me.
Yeah.
You guys can talk about
different clothing manufacturers.
Do you know any Eddie?
Do you know any clothing
designers and some of the coachee?
Bon Jor in those jeans?
[inaudible] Versace means
you don't remember bonds,
your jeans.
What about Sergio Valenti?
Listen,
this is all old stuff.
That's old school.
But what I'm saying is this motherfucker
could probably rattle off like gang or
is that still good?
Yeah.
Good.
She's good.
Just talking right now off whites.
The biggest brand in the world off white,
off white right now.
Dan,
a materialist woman's dude.
I'm a materialist woman's dream.
Think about this.
You're a big old gorilla of a guy.
You got big Dick Energy Fat Dick.
You're right about that.
You're a manly man,
but yet you're into fashion soup and
don't suck Dick with this jacket.
Leopard skin jacket on.
Nothing.
But the point is that you really do
enjoy it and you're not shy about it now.
Now love it.
This is what I like.
I like give me a name of an obscure
designer that you really love his work.
Mark Mason.
See her follows like women's
dresses and shit too.
Yeah,
like get all mad.
Like I'll tell him,
I'll tell my girl to wear
or like shoes or like a,
I saw Aubrey and Whitney had
on it and Aubrey had this,
uh,
or I'm sorry,
box and burn and uh,
Whitney had this Gucci purse.
I knew what it was.
I was like,
that person is sick.
And Tony's like,
what the fuck mate?
I'm like,
dude,
you just don't know what it is.
It's like,
well listen,
I don't know why.
Why did a style and aesthetics,
why did that become a homosexual
activity only or a female?
Yeah.
I don't know to where it,
this is why.
Because I bought that shit because
sometimes people want to staple a regular
shirt on the outside of a tee shirt.
Pretend it's not.
We're talking to you.
That's not fashion.
How many times,
if it seems to hold myself back a bunch,
but what's the 10 no.
Okay.
Zoo Lander.
The lander.
I never saw it,
but I've seen clips I've never seen so
ever since I heard the second one's a
bomber.
No,
you got to see zoo lander with Brendan.
You guys
smoke weed.
Yeah,
totally.
I was watching a clip the
other day from tropic thunder.
Oh my God.
Classic.
It's up there.
There's two things you
can't do ever again.
After tropic thunder.
You can't be a white guy
wearing blackface pretty cheap.
You can't say retard.
Well.
Yeah,
like simple is done so you
can do simple jacket again.
Yeah.
But remember you never go full retard.
I mean that was one of the
big lines in the movie.
You literally do that today.
You can't play,
you can't make fun of
playing a real person,
like four people that had
done blackface since this,
I mean a deal from Saturday night live.
Um,
there's a list of them.
No,
seriously,
I just a major motion picture.
Not a major motion picture,
but Saturday night live.
Even if I'm wrong,
like exactly.
Maybe someone did it afterwards
and culturally like that
is the last big moment.
You might be right that other
people have done it since then.
It's find out what was the last time
someone black face in the movie?
Did you know what Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle does white face
that doesn't care Mexican aisle.
That was years ago.
It doesn't extra time out on the
Chappelle show 10 years ago and he's also
doesn't count.
White faced is not the same as black face.
Black face existed back
in the Al Jolson days.
He ever see that shit.
You ever see?
Like when the minstrel
quite guys on black dudes,
you ever watch it?
No.
It's crazy.
You're like,
what is this?
Like what?
It's weird.
It is.
Fuck.
Look at that.
God,
Doug does.
So racer and he would
have to have white lips.
Is that this?
Does that make it official?
I don't think he looks
just like a regular black.
They just made it to hit lips look bigger.
I mean that's the,
that's what the white does.
100% yeah,
they're,
they're trying to make him
have exaggerated looking
lips because in contrast to
the black,
it looks like lips.
Just like when a girl puts lipstick and
she outlines it outside of her lips,
makes her lips look bigger.
That's exactly what
these people are doing.
So this is what they did and they
wouldn't let black people in the movies.
Black people couldn't be
like the star of a movie.
They didn't have to be a white guy
playing a black guy in black face.
Did you see Sean White
dress up as simple jacking?
Got Roasted for it?
Who Really?
Come on.
Shaun white is the Olympic snowboarder.
Monster gold medalists.
Yeah.
Math Games.
Flying Tomato.
You know what's crazy is like these
days you can't talk to my shit no more.
But the gender thing isn't
there like 60 some genders.
They're supposed to be a bunch of
different gender Telmo now like six,
right?
Yeah,
but they don't,
they're not saying is 60 genders,
but what they are saying is they should
have the right to dictate what pronoun
that that you use instead of him or her.
If they want like Xer orZ ,
they make up a bunch of these wacky,
but how many are there really?
There's man,
woman,
man,
dude,
born as man,
but it woman inside woman,
born woman,
but man inside.
And then the fifth one might be a man
who feels like he's man and woman and
maybe they're six or seven.
How many,
how many associate with that though?
Some of them say they
don't associate with them.
Then there's asexual that seven,
like one hand sexual guy who
doesn't think he's a guy or a girl.
What does isn't pan?
You just love to fuck pansexual,
whatever going.
It's all good.
I'll panel pansexual.
Is it Monday through Friday?
I'm a fucking dude.
Saturdays,
Fridays,
Saturday night.
I'm a fucking chick.
Yes.
Gender fluid.
Yeah,
they go back and forth.
I don't know why there was a
whole radio on the weekend.
There was a whole radio lab podcasts about
it and I was laughing my ass off when
I was listening.
To me,
there's parts of it that it
was so preposterous because
it was a guy who would
just decide while he's talking and he's
a girl and because this is like a super
progressive show cause radio lab
is this like really well made,
really high,
fucking super well edited.
They connect.
They literally can't say this guy might
have some problems with his perception
to reality.
Yeah.
This might not just be a gender thing
or maybe it is a gender thing or is it
split?
Right,
but you have to have both
options on the table.
Like this guy might be
fucking crazy and he,
the guy was a man.
Then you just go,
oh I just flipped.
I just flipped him.
The woman,
now it's this size.
He goes back,
he's the man again,
but you can't,
when it comes to gender,
here's the thing,
because he get mad.
You can't have these thoughts.
You can't question.
You can't cause I don't know.
I'm not him.
Right.
Maybe that's a thing.
Maybe you do just flip back and forth
from feeling like you're a guy or feeling
like you're,
or maybe that's crazy.
That's possible to be fucking crazy.
Then it might be some kind of
delusion that's involved in this.
Again,
maybe or,
but the thing is,
if he wants to do that,
I don't give a flying shit,
but don't get mad at me if I
don't call you the right prone.
If I don't call him right now,
I don't.
We don't know if he did get mad or
she got mad depending on who she was.
And what percentage is there a
high rate of suicide for people?
For dudes that chop their
dicks off transgender.
Right.
50% think whether or not they
go through the operation.
There's still a very high rate of suicide,
but trash.
Yeah,
transgenders,
50% so here's the,
you cut off your Dick.
You should be on suicide watch,
right?
I mean that's huge.
Well,
it's huge,
but I don't think it's affected them
that they regret come their dicks off.
Put the no the hormones.
I think that's what
fucks with their brains.
Stuff like,
cause then you're,
you're messing with the
biological system of your body,
right?
Yeah,
I came straight all that.
I think [inaudible] right,
man.
If you're a man,
but you're feeling like a woman inside,
I'd say it just keep your Dick.
You know what I mean?
Cause it's gonna it.
You Chop it off.
You're going to lose
all those orgasms minus,
we'll have orgasms to do.
You can't have orgasms
if you chop your Dick,
cause I'm doing chicks
were tits with fat Dick.
I don't think so.
Dicks,
they keep their pleasure.
Pat,
keep up.
You're going to get rid of your orgasm
unless you're born with like a deformed
Dick.
Oh my God.
I mean we're missing the
craziest girl Tko of all time.
This girl is getting smashed harbor
doing some cough drops and some horrific
bombs down.
Oh my God.
These girls are,
oh my God.
Big Elbow.
This reverence.
Damn Raf to get in the damn.
She got blasted
some shots.
Hey,
it's a fight game.
Yep.
So just getting paid for it.
Ah Damn.
That was wild.
She got blood on the full on it.
Shirt.
Powerful on it.
The ice man.
Shout out in the audience.
Shout out.
Oh,
I see Birdman back the
to what were we just say,
man,
what were we just saying?
Oh,
we're talking about
chicks with dicks and the
cut it off.
No,
keep it.
Keep the fun.
Yeah,
I mix it up.
It's plenty of dudes will suck it.
You know what I mean?
Probably.
Yeah.
That's probably a big number.
Go to Germany.
You go to Germany,
he west Hollywood up the street.
But the question is like,
do they get suicidal because
they're not accepted early in life?
I think the real question,
because this is what a
lot of the thought is,
is that they develop their self esteem
when they're very young and went there,
you very young and they're a boy and
they wish they were a girl and then they
get picked on for that or
they get fucked with for that.
That becomes like this very,
um,
very awful connection with this terrible
memory in this terrible feeling that
you feel around people who,
who hate you just because you're
different and then you are as an adult.
Yeah.
And then who knows what
else comes into play there.
Right.
Um,
you know,
alcohol and but also hate
crimes on transgenders through.
Yeah.
Like even,
uh,
Kristin Beck who was a
former navy seal and now she,
you know,
she's a woman.
She takes hormones,
but I don't think chopper Dickoff off.
You're talking about a navy seal killed.
Yeah.
Ton Of fucking people.
She was saying she was walking on the
street and some guys came up behind her,
hit her over the head with a
bottle just for being transgender.
I just knocked her out on the street.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking terrible man.
Yeah.
Yeah man,
this is,
it's just a lot of people that are
developed in a really fucked up way.
You know,
they've just seen too many awful things.
He childhood and think about all these,
all the people in this country right
now that are growing up in horrible
neighborhoods and what's
going to happen out of them?
What is,
what's going to happen?
What's going to happen?
These people,
you read these stories about Chicago
and parts of the south side Chicago with
just shootings like a
hundred and a weekend.
That kind of crazy shit,
you know?
Yeah.
If you lived in a place like that,
like someone was,
there was a comic who
said something I forgot.
I apologize.
I forgot who it was.
Who said something like this
on Twitter about how you get,
uh,
he's a black comic too.
You were saying that PTSD
is not just for soldiers.
Like you get it when
you grow up in the hood.
Oh,
that makes sense.
You see a lot of shit that you shouldn't,
you shouldn't see your route.
A lot of violence around a
lot of [inaudible] with a
different perspective when
you grow up,
a little shell shocked and um,
I mean that's,
that's a crazy way to develop,
you know,
super crazy.
Well thank God for these
pills that you could take.
Oh,
I don't know if those are the
answer or there aren't they,
but are they the answer for
some people sometime I think.
Yeah.
Some,
yeah.
Some people were on hanging on by a thread
there hanging out on by a thread and
someone comes along and they offer
them chemical escape from the,
the just the fucking sheer
misery of being alive.
And then it puts them in a place
where they can think about things,
does it,
where they can think about it.
Cause when you hear
like a Neil Brennan or,
but Neal Brennan was fucking most
brilliant comedian minds out there.
I wrote for a Chappelle show.
Brilliant comic has special on Netflix,
three mikes brilliant.
And he talks about how,
you know,
when he takes those,
those pills,
the prescriptions every
like he doesn't get high,
didn't get low.
It's just,
he's going through it.
Like you talked about his accomplishments.
He's like,
yeah,
it does nothing.
Like I don't feel anything.
They don't feel anything man.
That's terrible,
weird way to go.
Well do you know depression again?
Like,
like what we were talking about earlier,
it's,
it's on a spectrum,
just like mental illness,
just like all kinds of other different
things that occur in people because
everyone deals with depression.
We've all been little Preston,
but some people it sticks
like you can't get out of it.
And Anti conspiracy theory
pill when you get take a blue,
the blue pill,
like on the weekends you don't want
to hit up out false flags or nothing.
He does go out and just have fun and dude,
Arusha footjoy the marsh fee are used.
This is why I have its opinion on this.
You should fear used
antidepressants correctly.
And um,
he,
he had to try a couple of different kinds
and figure out which one really worked
for him.
But once he did it helped him.
I saw it help and he's a happy guy.
He turned his life around.
He see,
he got on the antidepressants and knees.
He talks about this openly.
Never share too though.
Right?
He got successful.
It helps as well.
He's still on him.
But who knows what came first?
The chicken or the egg?
No,
he weaned himself off of them.
But he got on them and they helped him.
And why did he have to wean
himself off as the health?
Because he didn't think
that he needed him anymore.
He thought that he was leaning on them
as a crutch and he would kind of reset
his mind and change your way of thinking.
Yeah.
And He,
you know,
he,
he and I talked about it and I'm,
I'm,
I'm trying to remember
exactly how he put it,
but essentially it was what he was saying.
I got another one to be
some limit that the Olympia,
you gotta taste.
Yes.
Olympia Shit.
It's delicious.
Just something about beer in a can.
I don't know what it is.
My,
my mouth was watering like
a crack head beer in a can.
Yeah.
But with art,
it's like success to make you happy.
Like I,
yeah,
for sure.
That man,
he's killing it.
He's killing it.
And I'm sure that had
something to do with it.
So maybe you get on it discounted.
But I think there's a
lot of things going on.
The depression,
a lot of the things you can't,
it's hard to narrow things down plus or
minus and thinking that it's one thing
that's causing you to be happy or
one thing that's caused db to be sad.
It's
very likely there's a bunch
of different shit going on.
Yeah,
you gotta,
you gotta remind yourself
every day of how lucky you are.
Yeah.
It's tough.
That's tough.
Fucking Thomas on realistic.
Not really.
You could do it.
It's just like working out.
You know what I mean?
It's the same thing.
You could put yourself an hour,
hour and a half thinking one way.
I'm going to work out.
I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking focus on,
on getting stronger today.
Focus on the reps and all
the sets and my routine.
You'll apply that to,
you know,
just for 15 minutes.
Just think about all the
shit you've accomplished.
Think about the money.
Have think about how lucky you are that
you don't live in fucking Liberia or
Guatemala or some shit.
You could be in that caravan right
now with the backpack throwing rocks.
You know what I mean?
So if you,
if you really,
and this is,
that's the real shit though.
That's not an illusion.
The real shit is that
you should be thankful.
The fake shit is not being thankful.
That's the fake shit.
That's,
that's the illusion.
It's not because you're so caught
up in like your daily life,
stuff like that.
But you know what I mean?
You know how quickly you would appreciate
your life if you got framed for murder
right now.
Just right now all of a
sudden your knife would be,
I had a little bit of a scare with my son
and it was like nothing else mattered.
Yes,
exactly.
That happened.
I was like,
Dad,
take my career to take this.
Perfect.
Exactly.
Importunate would it be want man,
just make him make it.
I was like,
maybe you have a verbal portion for real.
I'm like,
please make sure he's okay.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah.
Damn.
That's course like if you found out
you had five minutes to leave to live,
all you would think about is your kid.
That's all you would think about it.
Well I just got evacuated,
evacuated from my house
cause the fires fires,
they're everywhere.
They're everywhere.
They're,
they're in.
Um,
they ended evacuated like thousand oaks
and they evacuated places in Westlake
and cigarettes out.
Apparently this fire that we have here
is nothing in comparison to the fire
that's in upstate.
What further up northern?
The northern California fires
supposed to be even more severe.
They were saying that northern
California fire was moving it.
What was the number of something insane?
Like 80 football fields a minute.
Wasn't that what every label it?
The biggest fire California ever.
The biggest fire going on right now
in northern California to northern
California.
It's craziest as a how damaged
cars are getting there.
Like melt at cars are melted.
This bus,
this bus that looked like it was bombed.
Like how was,
how were fired?
We know how it's done in that.
I don't know.
It's always the worst when it's like
some fucking asshole started it.
I don't know.
I don't know if they know.
Crikey.
I don't know if they know
direct energy weapons.
It happened right
outside of a rocket dyne.
That's where it happened,
which is a,
it's like a rocket.
Have you seen those pictures
of the cars with their,
the rims are melting.
How hot do forest fires get?
They get hot as fuck.
How is steel mill out of aluminum?
It's a lot of aluminum wheels.
The frame doesn't show
just so goddamn blurb.
Aluminum wheels,
right?
Yeah.
Halloween.
Regular fire melts aluminum.
I'm just a regular fire will melt.
Your tires are going to let you know me,
dude.
You're asking me.
You're asking me do I think about
who you're talking to right now?
You got a couple of factors here
that I would just take into account.
Not being a fire expert,
but one of them want to think it would be.
Tires.
Tires are super flammable.
Once your tires catch fire,
they're all made out of rubber and
all kinds of other plastics and shit.
Just fucking Flambeau.
They go black smoke.
It's a crazy smoke.
That's why the cartel used and when
they kill people that put them into the
fucking
Dow.
Some with like lighter
fluid and I don't know.
The other thing I was going to say is
gasoline cars are fueled by gasoline.
Gasoline there you got fire,
you got insane heat.
The whole car gets in golf,
the gas tank erupts.
You got fucking
temperatures that are like,
it's like basically having
an inferno right there.
It's not like,
it's not a fire like oh a fucking phone
book caught on fire and it melted a
wheel.
No,
it's like a giant combustion engine that
works on gasoline and has these rubber
stopper flammable tires and it's covered
by a plastic paint that's probably
slammed Hobos,
flammable and this shit all gets hit.
Insides of leather with fire that's
coming from 50 mile an hour wind and fire
machines.
And then about like the the registration.
What the fuck?
I mean I'm just trying to be funny.
Oh I'm sorry.
I thought you were serious.
Look at these cars.
These cars got murked.
This is like what happened when
I met Loki on the Avengers.
They fucking destroyed Eddie.
That the heat makes them shatter.
They fall apart.
If you ever get a glass too hot,
you ever have a glass get too hot?
No.
If you pour tea in a regular glass,
they crack.
So that's not even that hot cause
it team makes them expand the,
the,
the heat from the T.
You're not buying it Hoodie.
I Dunno man.
Well it was fires aware.
This is what I would suggest.
Don't look into it.
Try Shit.
You know me affected by the fires.
Fires.
If CNN,
if the headline says anything,
I don't believe it.
Any,
anything.
That's true Eddie.
That's true.
Here's the beautiful
thing about this fire.
You can fucking see it.
You don't have to one on another fire.
I'm just saying like how it started.
This is what we're talking about.
We're talking about this fire.
There's a fire for sure.
Giant by the smoke.
So I don't know.
There's some crazy people
out there saying that um,
being started by some fucking
direct energy weapons.
Adol no,
that's what the crazy people are saying.
Well,
fires happen all the time though.
It's kind of a natural,
what's more likely that
fires are happening.
Like they always fucking happen from
electric boxes going out or wires going
down or people being
assholes with cigarettes.
That's how firefight before
there was Illuminati,
before there was anything,
there was forest fires.
They had been around forever.
This is not like a new occurrence.
It's not like they using this secret
energy weapon to do some shit that's never
been done before.
How done when they're super energy weapon,
if they use it to start fires,
there's just a lot of weird
shit out there like that.
Houses like you can see house,
house,
completely level all
the trees around them.
Nothing wrong with the trees at all.
Weird.
Just weird shit like that.
Well it's proud of knowing what these
are here for the fire to make fucking
houses go up in flames
because it's all dry old shit.
So dry wood hood,
you got dry old shit on the tile,
your tiles.
A lot of times these people have these um,
these roofing tiles in the
embers get in between there.
It goes right into the tar.
It burns it,
it goes right through my next door
neighbor is his roof was on fire.
[inaudible]
done well.
Yeah.
No,
they um,
they,
they got to it in time.
The firefighters caught it.
Actually my friend bud caught it,
told the firefighters to bud.
Bud Brotzmann.
Yeah.
His house.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't his house,
but it was my neighbor's house.
So when,
when this was all going down,
this is happening all throughout,
not just here,
but all throughout Topanga now and Malibu
and these embers fall from the sky and
then they blew the light.
Everything up in flames
because everywhere you look,
everything is dry as fuck.
Shit,
we haven't had any rain
in a long ass time.
If you go running in the trails,
it's just dust.
You're kicking up dust,
you start calling and
you got the wins breads,
all of it.
Everything's Brown and dried entity.
And when these embers fall
from the sky and hit this shit,
it just starts up.
We're just lucky.
It doesn't happen more often.
In fact though,
it happened this time last year
around here because we had a deal,
we had ash out in the gym area.
We had a sweep the ash out cause he had
actually come in through cracks like
little tiny cracks.
I'm bash,
although my house from his
fire all the way where I'm at,
I'm sure,
I'm sure it's no joke.
Dude was two shifts IV.
So I don't think it's an energy wave.
But I do think it's fucking
super dangerous to live
in a climate where there's
this much vegetation
and not enough moisture.
Like how come we can't figure out how to
get that fucking water out of the ocean
and start spraying it all over
so much water and you know,
it's just so much.
There's salt in it.
We can't fuck with it.
The can't fuck with us all.
Feel like they can take the salt down
until the can't fuck with the salt.
No,
no,
no.
They have desalination.
Plants are just too expensive.
That's too expensive.
We can't afford that.
They say this Guy Holman.
In fact,
if we only had more money
we'd be able to do that.
But it's too expensive.
The plants off the ocean water
now they use all our water.
If you got rid of almonds in
California will be straight.
Wow.
The almonds bro.
Vegans consumed more almonds
and then they were there.
The reason why,
the reason why the word.
Imagine how ironic that would be is
there as almonds that we're doing this in
the whole time,
not cattle raising.
Is fucking almond country rich enough
to filter the salt out of water and use
the water for their country or
is it just too expensive to buy?
I could do that shit.
No,
I don't have that much money
in a hotel.
They would roll out a carpet,
made a goal to do it slide and a
gold surfboard in that fucking song.
Builders,
like for the navy there's like a
survivor filter that you could drink the
seawater and you could like
suck and it's like this filter,
the survival thing.
I don't know about that.
I know they have been drink piss,
so they have those things for ponds,
they have these things
they're called steri pants.
Just can't figure out that seawater
and this cannot go that out.
What's a high salt content?
You too expensive.
Can't have that much salt content.
What if?
What if we have a water tax?
You know what I mean?
We're running out of water.
We got to figure out how to take
the salt out of the seawater.
I don't think this is a,
we have a task.
Plenty of fresh water though.
I don't think this is a conspiracy.
No.
You just said,
you just said how come we can't just take
the fucking ocean water and I was just
being funny.
I'll tell you why they can't.
It's fucking super expensive.
It's too,
it's just be a transplant.
Yeah.
Well kind of much money to change the
water and to do it all the time for all
the people.
Just pull that water out
and then who owns it?
Maybe if we bring some coke and from
Central America and generate income that
way.
Imagine if we started sucking
all the stuff out of the ocean.
The ocean started pushing back and then
people started building houses in front
of the people's houses in Malibu.
And at first they would,
at first they would go,
fuck you.
We have the beach.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's not the beach anymore.
So basically just got an acre
because I've read a book a mile,
just keep sucking water out.
Imagine this like a mile to the beach now.
And uh,
you know,
all these Malveaux people,
they show up at the fucking
county board meetings,
pulling the water out of the ocean.
He turned around behind him.
It's a goddamn tropical jungle.
We got monkeys in La and parents and shit.
Man.
We turned it into the tropics
when make it moist and delicious,
that that would happen is a
piece I'm gonna do a fight.
Uh,
real quick dairy.
She's a monster.
Yeah,
he is a beast.
He's just fell,
fallen on hard times a little bit.
He was ranked fucking high for a while.
He's a very good fighter.
Yeah.
He's so good at everything,
man.
And just very good.
Matchups he had a tough loss,
right?
His last fight.
He follows up to Martin.
Stopped him.
Michael Johnson recently,
but I forget it was Amy.
Can you pull up and
Neil Dahrouge she's um,
he had a tough flat on the ground.
Amazing.
Fucking striking.
I do not know much about this.
Saw fighting.
Say his name.
Moisis
oh.
Tiyaga.
Moisis these from att.
He fought an Ebi combat Jujitsu.
Oh,
no shit.
how good is he?
Uh,
it was hard to tell from one match,
but he's a black belt.
He's from American top team,
so he's gotta be a fucking beast.
The daddy jumped right in to kill it.
To eat.
That's a deep one.
Like,
Oh shit.
That we shouldn't be prompt to summit.
Wow.
That was tight though.
She has,
he got killed by Edson Barboza.
That's what we're thinking about.
Yeah,
that's exactly one thing
about by a flying knee.
And then Alexander Hernandez in his
last fight Caledon with punches,
but he's beat some good guys.
Like James is.
He knocked down that Tiago Moises,
he's gone for us going for it.
Fucking tough to submit him.
It's going to be,
but man,
he uh,
I think he has it.
Took his back and strangle them.
Yeah.
Did we do I love chess at 70 yeah,
he did.
He did,
right?
Yeah.
She,
I said seven.
I do like,
can we trouble,
he just was killing himself.
Makes you pay 85 yeah.
I love from hanging around him.
He's a wide fella.
He's a sturdy fellow.
Big Dude.
Big Frame.
He's me really good at 70.
He's,
he can give guys problems.
You know,
were,
I was doing commentary with Paul Felder,
you know,
and I'm standing next to Paul Felder.
I'm thinking,
how the fuck are you?
155 pounds.
That is ridiculous.
You're not 155 he gets bad to it.
People say,
you know,
this guy over here,
he's 200 pounds with,
Hey,
I was one 92 last two,
my bad.
He'll get upset.
That's hilarious.
He'll give you,
try to gain an extra
eight or 10 pounds on him.
He's just a big lightweight.
He's a big boy.
He's a powerhouse in thinking about it.
That was my Perry's last fight.
Last when my Perry can outclassed him.
Well,
what happened was,
um,
he bounced his forearm off of Mike Perez
head early on in the fight and he's
spinning back fist at him and hit him
with this part of the forearm right in the
forehead and snapped his
arm and half his arm.
So he's fighting with one arm and
fought like that for three rounds,
but he couldn't wrestle.
Okay.
So he couldn't shoot,
take downs or do anything
with his right arm.
He punched him with it a bunch of times,
even though it's still broken.
And he was trying,
he was trying to punch with
his leg was in fucking agony.
It's not just about power,
right?
It's about knowing that this shit doesn't
work anymore and you're going to try
to grab her hand.
And he got a guy tried
to rip your head off.
And Mike Perry,
super strong,
one 70.
He's a beast.
He's super aggressive.
He comes at you real hard.
He takes a tremendous shot.
He's got a fucking Iron Chin
and horrifying knockout power.
Tough matchup for Jake Kellenberger Elbow,
that elbow.
Kayla lucky like Jesus,
he's got real power but then
you know the guillotine.
But Paul Filter was kind of Mike Page
first wind where he's technical and stayed
on the outside hanging on that neck.
Yeah.
And then before that though,
like Alan Jobe and beat
him was super technical.
I think the move to Jackson's has,
it had a giant impact on him because
what I saw in his last fight,
I saw him manage distance
much better and pace.
He wasn't just like a marauding
psycho going after her own fate.
He's mixing it up.
You ain't go sit it up.
It was like very good footwork as well.
It was very technical.
So I think he's adding a lot
more technique and strategy
to what he already had.
The Tower series,
power series,
aggression can,
he had skills already.
It's not like you couldn't punch,
it's not like he couldn't,
you know,
but he was kind of one
dimensional a little bit.
We'll just so wild,
so reckless and so,
so hungry to fuck you.
What will beat a lot of
guys to get a certain level,
then they can deal with it.
But Kudos to him for recognizing Brilla
and then making some adjustments.
And I think he definitely did make
an adjustment in that Felder fight.
He looked amazing.
So it was on him.
He made the adjustment.
Um,
and he obviously put in
the work and look great.
And it was also on Felder breaking his
arm or pretty early on the fine arm.
But even before he broke his arm,
Perry was getting the
better of the exchanges.
He was,
he was more dangerous.
He was like,
there was more consequences.
He,
he's a,
he's a fucking scary knockout artists
stylistic wise for cowboy hits a tough
five days.
Well,
we both think that cowboys at
his best when he doesn't have to,
he doesn't have to fight guys that
are that much bigger than him.
You know,
I would rather see some
guy's tough cowboy.
I'd rather see him at one 55 then
see him fight Darren till again.
There was something about seeing him
with Darren till we see how big Darren is
at one 70.
He's fucking big man.
He's big.
He even talked about going to 85 and he,
he's going 85 now.
And you look at him [inaudible]
he changed his mind again.
Yeah,
he's like a thing.
It would collect 70
cause he was gonna fight.
Ask Her in at 70 them they
gave African Robbie Lawler.
Oh,
what?
Both fights I love.
But you know that guy's just so,
he was so much bigger than cowboy.
He was so much bigger.
Way bigger when you
looked at him in there.
I mean he looked like he was
two weight classes bigger.
At least one weight class.
Bigger look at ease.
At least on the upper end
of the next weight class.
Lawler makes sense.
What are you talking about?
Fuck yeah,
the reasons to not make sense.
It may make sense.
No,
it doesn't get to be hard to take down
and he's fucking vicious with this.
So none on the night of the fight.
I dig it.
But the thing that makes Ben
aspirins special to is his,
you know his mouth,
his mind came.
So rob not going to play that game.
He doesn't have a dance partner.
Oh,
that's what makes it
great is that he can't,
he can't.
Uh,
what?
What is it going to do?
This is the fashion lover and
you're talking none of them hold up.
No.
This,
this is the Dana white me talking.
This is the moneymaker.
Meet the your boys the exact same way.
Let me here because if you give Ben
Astron who can talk fucking right up there
with the best,
we got men.
If you give him a guy,
you know you name anybody,
you give him with anyone in the,
in the fight game and
he goes back and forth.
He's going to be great.
You can Colby Cummington
who's a shit talker.
Yeah.
The fans are going to be able to gravitate
towards that and see the story is
that first fight.
That's the first.
This is only one fight.
It's a big fight.
Robbie lumpy physically that shit.
Talking aside,
you're right with the
shit talking for sure.
X's and o's.
Amazing fight night,
but love the fight.
The physicality of the fight.
Is that a word?
Probably.
I like to work.
I'll tell you.
It's probably Jamie.
You got her name right?
Physicality.
That's a word that seems right.
Come on man.
That's the,
hold on.
This is no easy for Ben.
That's going to be a hard
fight is easy for him.
He just grabs everybody.
Fucking Manhattan.
I'm Sam for the Russian guys.
Same to take full advantage of what
Ben Asker and brings to the table.
Robbie Lawler is not the matchup
I would give them off the bat.
I would.
He gave him a Darren till or Colby come
into in something like that who will
verbally go back.
Got To build up to that has
been in the game too long.
I understand what the night of the fight.
Amazing fight.
I don't think.
I think you just want to see the fight.
I don't think we should ever
make decisions based on shit.
Talking Shit,
talking and encouraging shit talking.
I think what's interesting
about Ben asked her in his bed,
aspirin,
I want to see what the fuck he can
do to a real former world champion.
We're hardcore who's fought
at the highest level.
That's a great,
great match with you guys.
I love them.
I love Robbie lines.
I think Robbie allows the
legend whether he talks back,
no one's gonna give a shit.
Look,
Ben,
ask him when he was at.
That's not the world we live in.
Joe,
Ben,
ask him when he was at the UFC,
they put a camera on him
and the crowd went nuts.
He hasn't even fought in the UFC yet.
Everybody knows about
him from the Internet.
A lot of people know about him from you
and me and a lot of people know about
him from Bela Tarr fans and one fc fans.
I think people didn't realize how fucking
popular he is and how people want to
see what an undefeated,
undefeated wrestler who dominated guys
like Lima and Koresh carve and Bella tour
still hasn't dominated.
I want,
don't you want to see what the fuck that
guy can do and if you don't want to see
what that guy can do against
the fucking ruthless one.
Robbie Lawler,
Robbie Lawler's not done man.
No,
he's not done.
He's still be lunches.
He's alleged scary.
He's always scary,
man.
Pete,
he's had multiple like
periods in his career.
He had the strike force period.
Hey,
the UFC period here,
the championship period.
You know,
he had his younger wild days and
why he's fallen on some hard times.
He's not the greatest.
Robbie Lawler is not the
greatest wrestler of all time.
He's fucking wrestle growing
up and what the equalizer are.
His fucking hands,
dude,
his kicks,
Russell was everything you could say.
He's,
you know,
he's like right in there,
a decent wrestler,
but it's fucking hands.
Aspirin takes down and is anybody in the
UFC he made maybe pet he might finding
out he was going to be as
entertaining as fuck dude.
Again,
I think it's coming at me like I
don't think he's a great fight.
I'd love the fight.
I just went,
ah man,
I'm gonna get him Colby Covington.
I would have gave him,
that's coming.
That's coming.
This is after the first time world champ.
But or,
or Robbie Lawler gets Cubby
Colby Covington if he wins.
No,
that's a great way to,
for Robbie to get back into the mix.
And plus you don't want to make it easy
on Ben Ashman cause everyone's goal.
Yeah.
This to,
uh,
out of the UFC organisation champ.
Let's see what he's made of.
Robbie Lawler is a tough fucking tests.
Good take down defense.
But how can artists,
it gives roc nation an opportunity
to reset to if Robbie can beat him.
You know,
Robbie didn't have a good
fight with Rafael dos Anjos,
but he did have a good fight with cowboy.
Right?
Those were the last two fights he had,
I believe.
Am I right about that?
He lost dose on Jolson Cowboy.
He lost the Dos Anjos right?
Last raining.
It's cowboy.
Has Aspirin fought
anybody at Lawler's level?
No.
Right?
Lima.
Douglas Lema.
But also younger Lima
didn't wrestle growing up.
It was a younger Lima.
So I met the same cops.
A fucking monster.
But he's,
but both those guys,
he dominated them.
So they were young.
Lala brings in wrestling
and ferocious striking.
Also can't competition
at the highest levels.
Great champion in the UFC.
I mean,
he fought warriors.
He fought some of the best,
the vast,
I mean,
he's one of the best of best.
I'm interested in shit
times canny can't add.
Is there something about Lawler
that asked him can talk shit about,
what?
Can you say?
Nothing.
There's a few guys you
can't talk shit about.
It's fricking Robbie Lawlor,
Dan Henderson,
Matt Hughes,
like you just can't you remember Pete?
There's nothing there.
Before Tyron Woodley beat him,
people thought he was the
boogie man who Robby Lauer.
A huge scare.
The shit out of people.
I'll never forget Dana white at the comedy
store and like 2002 or three and he's
like,
it needs,
we're,
we're at the parking lot.
Dana white went to see you and he's
like raving about this new kid.
Oh my God,
I got this new kid,
Robbie Lawler's ferocious.
He's a wrestler who's just knocking
everybody out on the local level.
You're going to hear a
lot about Robbie Lawler.
I'll never forget that.
2001 2002 something like that.
Talking about a hall of Famer,
Legit Hall of Famer.
Yeah,
so for sure it's the toughest
opponent of Ben aspirins career or,
yeah,
I would say it's the toughest,
but for sure it's a tough validates.
Ben.
If he beats them.
I have to be totally honest.
I never,
I never watched his fights in one FC.
I'd never figured out
Ben's with you get it off
with the Russian wrestler.
He does one guy.
He's the best way.
I mean I just saw,
I just saw highlights.
I saw highlights too.
I didn't watch one FC either
one.
As soon as he puts his hands,
autos is at something's up.
But he has bionic hands or something
because as soon as he's able to get his
hands on,
he just doesn't let go.
And I'm not going to say names you down.
I'm not gonna say names,
but he does.
He does that to everybody and
guys we know that are good graph.
I mean if free bud.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I hear.
Which is why you and I both,
we went on like a goddamn
campaign to get that motherfucker.
How long did it take?
I know.
I love having him on the podcast was
great too because people could get to see
who he actually is,
you know,
because you,
you want a guy like Matt Locke and
these little shit talk and blurbs.
Like this guy an asshole.
Like who is this guy?
But then you sit with them
for an hour and he's fun.
He's fucking smart as shit.
Really well educated.
Looks like a Greek statue,
right?
Doesn't even get extra.
He take a shot like no one man.
He takes fucking knees when he
shoots and gets clipped with knees.
Not good enough.
The greatest spiders,
there's,
there's a couple others that you used
to used to campaign for the greatest
fighters that never fought in the UFC.
Ben Aspirin is one cause the other
one fader was a big black guy,
a black guy,
black guy who's never fought in the UFC.
Not Sad campaign for for 10 fucking years.
Man Home.
Oh yeah.
But it wasn't really fighting that
much MMA outside of pride rules.
Right?
Like he did.
Did he fought anywhere else?
He taught Bella toy data.
Fucking knock you into another dimension
or he's going to get choked out,
but either way you bring them
in his fight with Robbie Lawler.
How can we never got Melvin into
the you because you want an a man.
Is that what it was?
Once you suggest the fiber,
they're never coming.
Now you guys got it bro.
It's different hymns,
different name of fucking move.
No bed.
Dana hated Ben.
Ask Him.
They hated talk shit online
yet they went back and forth.
They chose brilliant.
Yeah.
Dana blocked him on Twitter.
Yes,
but valleys in,
I got ahold of Dana and I said,
he's a nice guy.
I said,
he's a fun guy.
He's talking it.
They ended up partying,
especially with Ben becomes changed shit,
Shitload of money to this and
they're going to be happy.
They made this decision as Ben.
He's not that old.
He's already probably
thirties early thirties
34 he's still fun to
do it for a hot minute,
but he still fuck people up.
Zero damage.
He didn't take a punch
in his last two fights.
He hasn't taken a punch in for like
you looked at the month it's been,
has ever cracked.
Solid.
Yeah,
he's been here.
He's been hit pretty hard
here on this list decision.
And He,
I remember the something
up he was telling me about,
I don't want to speak out of school,
so I won't even say what he said.
I don't remember what he said,
but there was an issue in his camp.
But this one was,
she was also striking a lot and he's like,
what the fuck am I doing?
You're not going to go in there
and do this and then change.
His whole demeanor was just like,
I'm bringing everybody down.
I'm not going to get hit.
Well,
Floyd Mayweather here on,
you know,
he's uh,
he's got real talent.
I mean,
Jay heroin lost to some really good
guys like George Saint Pierre and Tyron
Woodley.
But Jay heroin's a tough fighter and
he's got a good mix of wrestling and
grappling and it was a,
or a wrestling and striking rather.
And it was enough wrestling to get back
up when he was stuck on the bottom or
prevent takedowns or fight him off.
And they were looking at this man here,
this nice little squeaky reversal.
Yeah.
So he can actually wrestle a bit too.
And he hit it with a nice punch there.
So Jay here on good terms
with a spinning back kick.
Yeah.
So Jay heroin is a tough guy,
man.
Really,
really Jay here on restless all yeah.
Yeah.
He's a real wrestler and,
and he's also got a lot of experience
and had a lot of experience striking.
That was after he fought
George Saint Pierre,
right?
Yeah,
I believe so for sure.
That you have to check
to see if that's correct.
That's correct.
Cause I know Jay w w
that's after we've fought.
They fought after he got
released from the UFC.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
So anyway,
that was like the toughest
test of his UFC career.
But apparently there was another
fight that he had in one FC.
Now this is,
I'm getting this completely
second hand and I apologize,
but I'm just,
I didn't think we're
going to talk about this.
I didn't prepare this
or anything like that,
but I think someone was telling me that
he fought some dude and the fight got
stopped by an eye poke,
but that it was a tough fight.
The Russian cat,
it might've been the Russian cat.
Look at that.
Look at this fight.
Damn it dear.
You should feel that.
Who's got that body triangle?
I don't know.
Shit.
That's tight.
Oh,
close.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know if this is true.
This is just my guests and I think
the first person to utilize that body
triangle.
I'm authentically at a high level and
competition was John Jacques Machado.
Abu Dhabi.
Yup.
He was the first one.
I know there's old pictures
of catch wrestling with
guys and body triangles from
the back,
but in high level competition recorded
historical high level competition.
Abu Dhabi,
John Jacques Machado fucking ran through
guys putting that body triangle on the
back.
I remember asking him when
he got back from Abu Dhabi,
why were you putting the figure four lock?
You know,
while you're on the back,
why not just use the regular leg hooks?
And he said,
man,
when you're gone,
no [inaudible] is so slippery unit.
And he goes,
you got to lock in the hips.
And from that point on
that changed my game.
I'm like,
okay,
I guess when I get the back that's
going to be my main focus is putting a,
a triangle body triangle on.
And that was 1998 99 in that area.
Well a lot of people don't know how much,
well everybody knows you're
a John Jack Black belt,
but a lot of people don't know how
much John Shock style of Nogi is.
What influenced you to come up with a
lot of the positions in moves from 10th
planet.
Not only me,
but Marcello Garcia.
John John Machado was the first
Marcella Garcia of the Abu Dhabi.
Uh,
um,
historical archive.
Yeah,
he was the first one.
Because when you look at Marcella
Garcia and no doubt Marcella Garcia,
when you're talking about the
greatest grappler of all time,
Pete Marcella Garcia as right there in
the conversation can easily be number one
to say number one,
would it be Hixon I'm going
to say Marcella Garcia,
Jacques Hixon number one,
Roger,
Gracie,
um,
half a Mendez,
you know that level.
But the first one in
Abu Dhabi was John Jock.
When you look at what he did,
he was using x guard and
he was getting the back,
putting the body triangle is on the back,
was his shit and then Marcello
came and he was using x car to,
not that,
you know,
I'm not taking anything
away from Marcella Garcia.
Everybody,
anybody that knows me knows that I've
given Marcella Garcia more props and
fucking anybody living.
I'd uh,
uh,
you don't have to explain that,
but what I'm,
what I'm saying,
what I'm saying right now is
one of the greatest of all time.
Yeah.
And so is John.
Jack,
they're both two of the
greatest of all times.
There's a lot of that group.
John [inaudible] was the first Abu Dhabi
legend as far as finishing goes when
you're talking about the submissions,
because in those early Abu Dhabi's you
had a bunch of wrestlers who are masters
at controlling human
beings without clothing,
but they didn't know how to pass
and they didn't want to finish.
And then on the flip side you had
Brazilians who are masters of passing the
guard and finishing their opponents,
but they didn't really know how to
do it as well without the gooey.
So he had a lot of stalemate and going
on and a lot of bickering and bantering
back and forth about the
rule set and all that.
After the first couple of years,
it's like people,
you know,
you had the Jujitsu,
Jujitsu guys,
a stale mating with the wrestlers and
there's all this grease and all this sweat
flying everywhere.
And then enters John
Jacques and his first,
his first year in Abu Dhabi,
he submits everybody
and gets the gold medal.
So at that point people were like,
what the fuck?
This guy doesn't even have
fingers on his left hand.
How did it come in to Abu Dhabi?
And tap everybody and win the gold medal.
What is [inaudible] big like really big.
Yeah.
We just had the trials two weeks ago and
it was the biggest trials of all time.
The truck,
there's like 60 70
people in each division.
Dan,
think about that shit is it?
Gosh,
it's bigger than ever.
She's just a switch.
Complete gears to,
how about that?
Bare knuckle boxing.
I finally caught watching it.
Did you see in this weekend just not
fill brony Hendrix got knocked out but I
watched like exciting shit was boss
route and doing commentary was pretty
excited.
[inaudible] or just boxing?
Just fucking box.
You know you guys are,
he's talking about he
don't want gloves and shit.
Redo it again.
Fucked up.
You should be all over that shit
just to be on our own league,
Bro.
Bare knuckle boxing as they
do in the states or Russian.
It was here.
Listen,
don't give me a job,
Brendan Shop.
I have to do it.
Anything that boss ruin attached to.
Don't boss Dude.
How about bare knuckle MMA?
That's next,
right?
Well it should just be tough.
It should be.
Call it coc.
How is that boxing happened?
How?
How hard is it going to be
to have bare knuckle MMS?
[inaudible] we're
just trying to stay,
you know and amaze in like a motherfucker.
We don't have to be arrests
all proper for anybody.
MMA is not going anywhere,
so we don't have to.
Let's be loaded down.
If you could smash your
elbow into someones eye,
if you could smash and elbow
your elbow across someone's nose,
into their face,
into their mouth,
over and over again into their lips,
into their teeth,
their mouth guards.
You can do that with your elbow.
Why can't you punch them?
Free.
Normal person.
I don't mean normal.
Every casual fan turns on Fox and ESPN,
wherever it's going to be on,
and they see dudes with nothing on this.
Michael,
this is barbaric.
Reebok in rivers where if people thought
something and that something was not
true,
what do we do?
Do we educate them or do we go,
well,
not when we can.
Do people just think differently.
They don't know any better.
Know team football.
Get rid of helmets.
Yes,
you really should.
You know why that's they think
that'd be the one thing quit.
What kind of leather type
thing they used to wear them.
That George
[inaudible].
George [inaudible] still white dude.
Super White Leather helmets on
people would do to ruled support.
You're talking about Babe Ruth,
you're sober rating.
There wasn't one
when Jim Bro,
shut up.
Have you seen those highlight those epic
runs of Jim Brown and it's all white.
He's putting on moves on these
white guy to do it though.
First Black Nick came in
baseball and was like,
what the fuck you're Dominican game over?
Jim Brown had some of them.
You got to watch his
greatest fucking runs.
Oh,
better than Barry Sanders and Oj Simpson.
He's a better lacrosse player.
Yeah,
he's a Masha.
Imagine playing their with Jim Brown
and he's allowed to hit you with that
stick,
right?
A little bit.
Fuck yeah,
a little bit with that stick.
How much hit and make that stick?
Can you get away with it?
You can hit the arms.
You just can't hit the heavy
closest colleges as any of us.
What?
How hard can it be?
Both.
I played the college.
He played it.
I played it.
Yeah.
Well,
how much can you beat each other?
We can beat the shit each other.
Your arms.
It's the way they have pads in the arms.
You hit the arms,
the stick.
You can,
you can literally fucking court.
Oh Shit.
How was this sports still around?
Let's cross.
It's one of the oldest
sports in the world,
man,
but here's the started it.
It looks kind of fun.
Basketball.
Oh my God.
People get fucked up.
Okay.
That dude just got way late.
That's not illegal.
Nah,
man.
On a Saturday afternoon.
Why not get a minute?
Wait a minute.
You're allowed to hit
each other with the stick.
Run into each other like that.
Make the stick.
Have contact with that head.
Yeah,
it's
hockey on fucking grabs.
It's warm.
It's a great game.
Great game.
If you like concussions,
it's a great game.
It's causing you watch,
you watch.
How often do you watch it?
The first one,
and that's fun to play.
If there's a game,
that's great.
That means you watch
it when you follow it.
It's not great if you don't watch them.
The problem is it great.
I love it.
I love to follow.
I don't want to either.
In Jujitsu is great,
then you don't like
are missing these Kaos up in Lacrosse.
Oh Jesus Christ.
They're whipping their
fucking stick at each other.
Dude,
this is chaos.
You got to sacrifice kickboxing for this.
You've got to follow this down,
but let me tell you something.
They're striking each other.
This is not like just,
that's a strike.
They said their elbow
strike in each other.
They're not like just
running into each other,
do,
doing way worse.
They're hitting each other with the
sticks and their Koa and each of them.
Now Imagine Jim Brown.
Oh my God,
there are you going to watch each other
and smashing elbows into each other's
faces.
Rough and you gotta be fucking
athletic to be a midfield's.
Go back and forth the cardio
machine overnight in the cardio.
I'm not denying the ferocity.
I'm not denying,
I'm not denying the size
of these guys balls.
I'm not denying that.
I'm just saying if you ain't following it,
it's,
it's okay.
At best.
Yeah,
I mean I can,
the college us,
you know,
people say I love all music.
I love all you like Mariachis like that.
I love every style.
How many Maniaci cds do you
have in your car right now?
All of them.
All
you like Polka.
You remember what he liked?
Like a 12 disc CD changing ball,
ma'am.
And you pushed it into the cartridge.
Chuck Chinese dude,
I have a thousand cds
in the back of my truck
changers.
Like everybody,
if you were a ball,
you at a tissue 12 this
change go with number six.
So our stereo store with
him and he would just,
Joe,
we'd go in and just give me the best shit.
How long ago was that word?
Well,
once he money,
I just wanted a sound.
I wanted to hear what the
best stereo sounds like.
It sounds both.
Didn't you say that word for word gives
me the figure out what to do and I said
that shit.
Do the best shit.
Like what sounds the best?
What car was it then?
That was a Porsche 911 six twin
turbo and endure a Barracuda
Acura NSX.
All that
makes an experience better.
He had like the high
level Nsx back in the day.
This was like tire barn
and we were at Jujitsu any,
he had a bucket tear and he
couldn't walk and he goes,
you got to take me to
the prolotherapy people.
And I had a driver's NSX and
I knew how to drive stick,
but high performance
sticks a little different.
So we were panicking.
He's fucking holding his needs.
He scream,
you go,
you've got to take me to prolotherapy.
And I joined the drivers,
go to the prolotherapy doctor.
You the MRI.
Yeah,
and I grinded his gears a
little bit and his fucking
steam
follicles.
He was holding his leg and he's going,
you motherfucker,
don't cry my shit.
And I'm like,
you
were so mad.
I know you've got your artistic,
I'll never forget that.
I forget everything except
the cultural moment stick.
And I said,
yeah,
know how to drive a stick.
He's like,
yeah,
I got you bro.
I actually lied and I didn't know he did.
I knew all my first car was a
Ford Pinto snake stick in a while.
I remember those little tiny sports cars,
two seater Fiat's I had one of those.
Those are the styles dude.
For a month I was driving around at 19
with the little two seater yellow Fiat
Kahn.
I'm the fucking man until it broke
down like all Fiat's do and I,
I drove for a month.
We could never figure out
how to fix that motherfucker
fee out repair man.
And it was a mid engine dude.
That thing was so like it
was a fix it again Tony.
That's what the outstanding for dude.
Dude.
I,
there was one day when that car broke
down I realized who my friends really
were.
Nobody wanted to come
pick me up for parties.
I one night I started crying
like I don't really have any real friends.
Everybody was partying,
everyone was going out.
Cause I lived,
I lived in like kind of far how far
and I was the one picking 2025 minutes.
Tell you that's why I was crying.
Why do you think I was crying?
I'm like,
I love the friends.
Yeah,
you're cool.
But 25 minutes is a long way
trying to fuck this girl.
I realized how important cars were.
Never forget when my with up on blocks
in my garage and nobody could figure it
out on.
Nobody could figure it out.
Dude,
how great is this?
They're doing this throwback.
This is like the throwback logos.
Dope anniversary.
This is the first time
Jermaine Deronn to me is fun.
How crazy is that?
So,
and then there's Raquel Pennington
who is just a beast to high breakouts.
Okay,
check this out.
How sexist is the UFC?
Think about this
in a joking way.
There's a joking way.
But when,
when Raquel Pennington five Amanda Nunez,
the one thing they had in common was
they both had girlfriends that were UFC
fighters.
They don't touch on.
Everything was fine.
Everything was going
and it should be cool.
But can you imagine if there was two
male fighters fighting for the belt and
they both had boyfriends,
they were all so UFC fighters to him.
How crazy is that?
We don't,
we don't get that sexist though
because we don't let guys do that.
We're okay with girls though.
When he made the UFC want to give
a fuck if DC and Jon were gay,
they come up there.
You don't think,
you think,
you think they would be okay with that
hundred percent as long as they were
winning fights,
they don't care.
But here's what you have
to take into consideration.
I don't think there's been any suppression
of a gay fighters and promotions.
There hasn't been enough promotion.
It's probably super hard for some
gay guys to get acceptance in gyms.
Exactly.
It's got to be a gay gym,
right?
It's gotta be a gate.
Someone who runs a gym is super open.
Miners got gotta be gang kickboxing,
gay.
You can be a guy,
that'd be easier.
But check this out.
Check this out.
Because the problem is fight cultures,
old culture and that old old culture
from the boxing days and a lot of the
wrestling days,
like there's this thought of,
you know,
it's not the most
progressive concept that,
uh,
you know,
gay guys,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
Celt Pennington,
there's,
there's not a sense of the quality.
Check this out,
don't,
isn't it?
This is my theory,
my theory that show there's a,
there's a disproportionate amount
of female lesbian fighters,
uh,
having success in the UFC,
and this is my,
this is my theory.
You know why?
You know why this is,
my theory is their training
camps are not disruptive.
If they were heterosexual,
everybody would be making moves on him.
Their Dietitian.
That's exactly kick boxing trainer.
Everybody's going to be trying to make
moves on them when they're lesbian.
Everybody just treats them like a guy
thinking this,
this is real.
This is really a factor,
but I don't think that's awesome.
I think Holly Holm,
I think there's just some women like to
fight and maybe more lesbians like to
fight.
That's true.
More draw to it.
Straight women like to fight too.
I think their camps or less
disruptive because you take a girl,
okay,
let's just take a girl
probably like facts.
Like let's take a small thing.
The second UFC fighter that
looks as good as Paige vanzant.
Yeah,
she's just like that.
Imagine all the Dick that's going
to be thrown at her every day.
The dye houses.
You want a chiropractor.
If she was single,
boxing was
even if she's,
if she's actually,
especially if she's single,
can you imagine the drama involved?
Trust me,
I'm in the fucking fight
game the girls are getting,
if you're a heterosexual
girl and you're in the,
you're in a Jujitsu being a hot moraine.
Exactly.
But if you're lesbian and you're
hardcore guys still trying to forward,
but you're not,
dude aren't going to go for it.
They're going to treat you like a dude
and you're going to have a drama free
training camp and a school
and you're going to,
you're going to this small,
you're going to stick
with the school lung.
Look at all the lesbian fighters.
This is,
we'll stick with the trainers
because they stick the best ones.
The history.
There's no drama,
no drama.
But this is what I think is
what you're saying is true.
What you're saying is correct,
but this is just a factor.
There's a bunch of fallacies.
Beautiful rose.
Yeah,
she's beautiful and raw,
but no,
no rose.
All the top fighters are lesbian.
I'm just saying there's a disproportionate
amount of top fighters that are
lesbian and I think that's because you
know when you'll feel like we're all on
the June rose Dama Junis got a gigantic
gorilla boyfriend that will fucking
stomp on there.
Yes.
That's different.
Can you imagine a Rose Rose
normal Junius was single.
Can you imagine all the Dick,
they would be flying at her like she'd
be doctoring shit like the Matrix.
Respectfully.
You're right,
right.
Hundred percent.
There's less drama dude.
Cause in Jujitsu,
not even striking a
restaurant just in Jujitsu,
heterosexual girls.
But that's Thomas comments field though.
Hold on.
Exactly.
Even women are,
that's proving my 0.0 at an MMA gym does
the way more contact with a guy and a
girl.
Two girls,
two girls are,
are,
are uh,
are more prone to switch Jujitsu schools.
Then she got a postcard would die,
right?
Cause they start dating a guy
from another school and they go,
you know what,
let me go train at that
school on Saturdays,
they started training on the school on
Saturdays and then the guys that their
schools are like,
what are you trying to go over there?
And,
but dudes don't do that.
But the girls do that because you know,
because they're heterosexual.
I think that there's a ledge.
There's a little bit,
I'm not saying it's the be all end all.
I'm going to sound,
I don't think chicken bones.
I don't think UFC highlights
Amanda Nunez enough being lesbian.
She should be on fucking every
poster in West Hollywood.
Now check this out.
Check this out.
We don't fuck out of
Raquel Pennington who,
who's a beast.
Shit.
Think about,
think about onstar music marketable.
Then think about the music.
There's a disproportionate amount of,
of of all,
I would say 90% of my
favorite singers are gay.
I love this singer's singer Peter fucking,
oh,
I'm not even going to say his name.
I don't want to bust anybody out.
I'm just going to say,
uh,
no,
no.
Who knows?
Uh,
Freddie Mercury,
whatever.
But what I'm saying is
there's a disproportionate
amount of gay vocalists out
there,
right?
Think about currently and
gay Broadway can drive.
You would think of people
that perform on Broadway.
You think that these to
a healthy percentage,
and think about this,
we all know this,
we all know this in the music industry,
there's a lot
of gay music producers
and music executives,
right?
And they do creepy shit,
Not because they're gay,
just because the guys
that you guys happened.
Cause the dyes guys do creepy shit and
you're going to do creepy shit with
girls.
Or if you're gay,
you're going to do creepy shit with guys,
girls in district court.
There's a disproportionate
amount of gay singers out there.
And how was that heterosexual singer
going to compete with the gay singer when
they're ready to suck dick
at the drop of a fucking hat?
You know what I mean?
Well,
how bad you want to be.
Batman references jungle
with a lot of guys.
I'm not saying anything.
I'm just saying there's a lot
of gay singers and there's
a lot of gay and I love
gay singers.
Most of my favorite
singers or gallons arguing,
I'm sorry,
let me phrase it this way.
Are you saying that the same way that
like have a gal was trying to get into the
music business,
she could potentially run into some own
scrupulous males in the business who
prey on young girls trying
to enter it to the business?
Exactly the same.
Exactly.
For young guys with gay guys,
if they're gay,
they're willing to suck
that producers Dick.
And if they're not,
if they're straight,
it's going to be hard.
There's some
dudes in bands like bass
players and drummers are like,
do we need a gay singer to
get a deal up in [inaudible]?
So they look for gay singers.
I don't know the music industry.
Oh Shit.
Look at that Germain de Randamie one too.
That was nasty.
You know,
one of the worst champions of all time,
but it's fucking skilled man.
Dude.
Really high level stand standup,
14 time world champion,
some shit like that.
Very,
very good striking but did not
want nothing to do with Cyborg.
Isn't that fascinating?
Literally it was like,
you know what,
I have to hand her town.
She beat Holly should be here.
Well,
here's why I agree with you.
Holly clanged her with a question
mark kick and dropped her.
She had her stunned with that and then
she dropped her with a straight left
hand.
Those are two hugely significant moments.
He only significant moments really?
Well there was Jermaine hit
her after the bell twice,
twice and I think the second time you
should have taken a point away because it
was,
it was,
they were hurting her.
Did the last one she
landed after the bell.
I think it was,
was it the second round?
Oh.
Oh Shit.
Hey Jermaine piece.
Solid fucking strike or petty shit.
Did you hear what we're saying?
Champion dude?
No,
she's a multiple time world champion.
Her kickboxing is out of this world,
man.
She had some insane kickboxing record.
Jamie pull up or cake.
Well,
I'm surprised they gave Raquel Penton
this fight and I'm just an awful fucking
beast man.
Not when it comes to the shredder.
Well,
she's just fighting a woman
who's just way better than her.
So it was Amanda Nunez fucking record.
Those are all wins,
son.
No world champion.
Dude kicked loads 37.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
Dude.
And he's Lanky.
She's got wide shoulders
nightmare to deal with.
Here's the thing,
man,
here's the thing.
She didn't,
she work CyBorD and she,
because she doesn't want
she the fuck out cyborgs.
Two big cyborg she said was a perennial.
What'd you,
what'd you call her?
[inaudible] user or some shit.
She had like a,
like a,
I don't want to,
I don't want to misquote.
Scared was like,
you know what,
I'll vacate the belt.
Fuck that noise.
I'm going to go back paraphrase.
She essentially was saying that Cyborg
has cheated and that she's used steroids.
I don't know what [inaudible] is.
And she said because of that
she didn't want to fight her.
The first set her hand hurt.
Then she was like,
you know what,
fuck national on this.
She said she needed thumb
surgery and she didn't.
Um,
she brought that up like immediately
when I asked her about fighting Cyborg.
But I think sideboards the
Bogie woman to these people.
That's what I think.
I think she's so much
bigger than everybody else.
I mean she's cutting down from
one 75 one 80 or beat the shit.
Even she is not sure she'd
get up to shake it up,
shake it up there bro.
She,
she a big woman to one 35 no,
41 45 45 do,
don't want to fuck with her
two to five with that girl.
Think about how big Conor is condor's
walking around at one 70 ish.
Right.
And he used to cut down to one 45.
Yeah,
this,
think about that.
Now cyborg basically
somewhere in that same range.
That's what's going on.
Yeah,
that's huge.
That's a lot of weight.
A lot of weight to cut somewhere in the
one 70 and maybe it made me even during
the off season two,
she gets even heavier.
[inaudible] me just hit her with
a fucking nasty straight leg.
How bout the fucking Amanda Nunez
Cyborg fight ended December.
Jon Jones,
Guzman St Clark.
Do Small grants to small looks.
So nasty.
Look.
Kind of good.
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta go to 10 planet 15
year anniversary party tonight.
Bobby Lee's gonna perform.
Sam Tripoli's going to perform
Simone Leigh Psi at Bobby Slayton.
What time's it start?
It starts at a right now.
Damn.
I gotta get Outta here.
He sat on it 15 years,
baby.
Damn.
Congrats with thank you ma'am.
Did you were there that
first day 15 years ago.
God Damn,
that's not a time flies
like a motherfucker.
Taz.
Dude.
Dude,
I have so many black belts.
It's incredible.
I got today we had a business meeting
because this weekend is the 10th planet
eclipse weekend.
We do it every year and
we have the holiday party.
We have a quintet at 10 versus 10 show.
That was last night.
There was insane.
Here's those quintet's are amazing man.
And then tonight we have the party
and then tomorrow we have the 10 Pq,
which is the 10th planet
qualifier for the next Dbi,
which is a,
the strawweight girls.
Uh,
man.
Um,
did you get a legit business?
I just rounded.
I'm surrounded by dudes who can kill me.
I got all around.
I might,
these motherfuckers,
if they wanted to,
they could just end my life.
Right now you've shown no,
it's pretty crazy.
Your master split is pretty much turtles.
I got fucking budget turtles
and Saturday all around me.
You know,
Shit ever hits the fan,
you know?
Um,
you want to be hanging
out with Jujitsu clans.
That's for God damn sure.
Unless it's a fire,
but you two people are generally more
calm because they're going to war all the
time.
They get all that shit
out of their system.
They're way more chill,
you know,
the way more,
uh,
no relax food.
How easy it would be just to put
someone in a rear naked choke.
And he was like,
you know what?
Yep.
You know,
if you don't train,
if you don't train and you're
not a doctor you're doing,
if you're not a doctor or some kind
of macgyver and you don't train,
we're going to have to eat
you to what you said before,
the podcast was so funny
about the apocalypse that
homeless people are going to
be psyched because it'd be like,
ah,
people waiting,
waiting for the end of the world.
They're taking the fires because
they're going to be running shit.
They're going to be the cause.
They know what they're doing.
They know the spots and shit.
The good is not going
to change their life.
It might get better.
What's going to get crowded?
Dude's in favelas.
If you live in a favela,
you don't have to worry about them in
the world cause it's already the end of
the world for you.
You know what I mean?
You already got your Shit mastered.
Most people that are walking around
pushing shopping carts with all these
plastic bags hanging off them,
they're probably most likely mentally
ill batshit crazy where I'll probably be
able to,
it's probably mk ultra throwaways.
It's probably a tag trafficking
throws his way to that.
Yeah,
it might be.
It might be.
I think some of them have to be some
throw away cause we all know a trafficking
is going on and I'm like
what happens to these people?
We know a lot of them are veterans.
That's where it gets real scary.
Super.
Dot of them are veterans.
A lot of a lot of veterans come home and
they don't know what the fuck to do and
um,
you know,
oh that scared me.
I said be McGregor but it
says now available and bypass.
I was like,
oh my God dude,
you're the best.
Congrats man.
I'll call you later brother house wedding.
Rehurt
later let her dude to sit over here.
I'll feel what's can be weird,
right?
Uber driver,
that friend and you have an extra friend,
the friends in the front seat and
that friend leaves and the friend,
the back seat stays in the back seat.
Like,
hey man,
you got to get up here.
Fuck this dude.
Jam Germane to Rhonda.
Me Looks Spooky.
She is so dangerous because
she doesn't do anything wrong.
You know,
show calculating.
It's super like super technical
with her movements too.
And she's basically playing like a,
a rhythm dance.
She's forcing Raquel into movements,
but she has the solutions to those
movements like several steps ahead.
But here's the thing,
Joe,
think about how many more fights
Dramamine it's been in that Kal,
I [inaudible] cold remotely.
Well not just bands
factor at a high level.
Pennington would have to really
struggle to take her down.
She's a one 45 or in Pennington
has been fighting at one 35,
you know,
and Jermaine dropped down
to 35 for this fight,
right?
Is this the 35 or 45?
35.
So Jermaine dropped
back down to 35 after
that 145 pound fight.
Oh Shit.
Head kick.
Um,
so she's super strong for the weight
class and it didn't [inaudible] tough
record to the salty six and five or some,
she's type shit.
She's as tough as they come.
You know,
one of my favorite finishes
ever was her versus Ashley,
Evan Smith,
because he was just
this wild fucking fall.
And then she catches her in a bulldog
choke and puts her unconscious for like a
second to the last fight.
And Deborah to was,
she's from Colorado Springs so they
usually put on the Denver cards.
I think I'm a fan.
I'm a fan too.
She's just so damn tough man.
But Duran me,
I just,
I hate this matchup for
after fucking Amanda Nunez.
Well it's a scary matchup cause she's
ranked number foods that uppercut goddamn.
It's scary because it's,
it's real similar and maybe,
you know,
Duran to me is even more a more
lethal with all the different things.
I'm not hating on all,
but trend me looks identical to the gang.
Kickbox kickboxer that beats
the fuck out of junk club.
[inaudible] friend,
the scary dude who's kicking the walls.
The thing about Duran to me that makes
her just see for sure Amanda Nunez has
more power and she'll assault you and
she's more aggressive and reckless.
Like she comes after you,
uh,
Nunez.
Yes.
And she's a murderer.
Power and more power at her
hands are just stuttering speed.
And then she's not so
black belt on the ground.
She's a bit of a beast,
but I think it's the
power is the difference.
But Duran to me has the full arsenal,
you know what I mean?
Like as far as her tech,
she's a surgeon.
Yes.
That's a good way to put it.
Everything she,
all of her striking is dumped
so efforts effortlessly.
It's all efficiently and smooth.
And there's no like weird,
like moments where hands are down.
She's lunging or footwear Ballance never.
The only time she,
you know,
struggled severely.
It was against Holly Holm,
who's also a worldclass boxer and
tricky because Holly is different than
probably a lot of the
strikers that she faced.
He's a big boy.
Thai people.
Yes she is.
Because she's very strong.
Athletic.
Yeah.
And she also has got
sneaky shit that she does.
Like that question mark kick,
you know what I mean?
She claimed her right off
the head with that one.
You know,
that was a big moment because Duran to
me was in the beginning of the fight was
kind of controlling the page
and controlling the rhythm.
And Holly had a finder spots and,
and a lot of people thought she
could have won that decision.
It was,
it was real close.
It's a tough spot for [inaudible] me
where they go and now you're fighting
Cyborg.
And she's like,
fuck that man.
So then you know she had
stripped of the title.
We all shit on her,
but it must have been a tough position.
Well,
if she has real feelings
about this and she really,
oh,
something happened.
What happened?
Grabbing the shorts.
I don't know.
Something happened.
Hit her in the titty.
Did she go low?
Did they take,
did they take a cooler shot?
Do you pause?
So I took it.
What happened Jamie?
What happened?
I poke the pussy shot.
Was it?
Come on.
Was it,
I think it was either
shorter fence grabbing.
That guy's a hard part.
It might be a sense grabbing fence or
it seems like the given her a chance to
recover.
God it,
I wish we were paying attention.
It's something happened.
Can we rewind a bit?
Oh,
but then we'll fuck everybody.
Yeah,
it'd be a nightmare.
She dragged me.
Just apologize.
I wonder what it was.
It seems like a f a Pho strong.
I'm strong J oh,
nice.
Neat fuck but not,
but doesn't go net lateral
notice straight back.
Right.
Still good takedown defense,
but accepting the fact that clinch is
definitely going to happen as opposed to
like almost wants to clinch.
Well almost maybe a fire.
It's also the end of the third and
she's been winning all the rounds,
so she's like,
all right,
cool man.
Let's say for me.
Yeah,
I'll just knocked down to myself.
Let me catch my breath and then get
you off me and finished around strong,
but she's going to have a
hard time getting her off.
Dude,
I'm nervous for these next two fights.
The Korean Zombie one's
interesting because yeah,
there's been out for a hot fucking minute.
Mary,
he's base.
He signed with Bellator,
like he was going through that whole thing
where he turned down as a beat fight.
Then they go,
right,
if you're not fighting to beat,
we're going to cut you.
Then he's a guy
and then they're like,
write your findings.
A beat.
There's a beat.
Pulls out two d step.
Beautiful one right hand,
left hook,
right leg kick.
Do.
She's fun to watch,
man.
She got a bad rap because the,
you know,
some on the Cyborg stuff.
Well,
you know what man,
it is what,
that is what it is.
We've said so much about that.
There's really no reason to
continue to talk about it now.
Just want to look at the
reality of who they are today.
Cyborg is just waste carrier
than any of those girls.
One of the things that makes Amanda Nunez,
uh,
interesting as an opponent
for Cyborg is first of all,
her last fight with Raquel Pennington,
she showed a lot of movement.
I think she needs a shitload
of movement in this fight.
She would need all the moves.
She needs to be in fucking shape.
She needs to be in serious shape
and she needs to be strong rounds.
And this is one of the things that
Amanda noon that said at the press
conference,
the press conference,
press conferences is interesting
because Cyborg was accusing her of,
uh,
I think not fighting
or at a previous time.
And she said she needed more time.
I think they wanted to
try to do those too.
They did.
They'd be trying from Madison Square
Garden while Amanda Nunez goes,
I need more time,
which I actually liked that.
I liked that too because she's the
smaller woman coming up as 135 pound
champion,
challenging the hundred 45 pound champion.
She's going to have to put some
weight on to want to keep it on and be
comfortable with it on and hopefully
get above one 45 so she can cut a little
because the reality of
Cyborg is she's way bigger.
She's probably walking around.
How many,
how many pounds bigger
would you guess then Amanda?
Just naturally,
just naturally 25 30 probably.
What did you think?
There's a number I
would like to play with.
That number is at least 20 [inaudible].
Say It would be 2020 to be fair.
20 pounds.
That's entirely possible.
It would be 20 so if Amanda Nunez is the
hundred and 35 pound women's champion,
what does she actually
way we're saying if you,
if you think the Cyborg is,
let's give her,
it was be generous and say
it's in the one seventies yes.
And then she cuts down to one
45 and we don't know by the way,
we just have red things.
I would like to know like let's see if
Cyborg has ever commented on what she
weighs before she starts her weight.
Cut.
Lock,
high sixties right?
Maybe let's,
let's get crazy and say it's one 60
even one 60 would be a lot of weight.
Bigger than a man of Nunez,
wouldn't you think?
100% what does Amanda Nunez way 50 you
think she weighs one 50 when she walks
around normally and cuts down to one
35 [inaudible] she's very strong.
Rock stuck,
jacked.
She's got all that back power man,
when she punches,
she fucking has the longest
punches like you my favorites.
But she's,
she punches so long.
It's like she's hitting you with science
team and she's hitting you way at the
end.
And she's fucking aggressive as shit.
But um,
so maybe let's say she weighs
one 45 one 50 at the most,
let's say 50 at the most.
Cyber could be one 70 she
could be bigger than one.
She's rolling around sixties
you think she's in her sixties?
Yeah.
She thinks she's in his sixties now.
Or you think she's in
the 60s all the time.
Do you think she gets bigger than that
and then fleeing from talking with her
and uh,
her manager,
her boyfriend,
she walks around at one 85 Jesus used to,
she said,
oh my God.
She said,
okay.
This one,
she's approaching UFC two 19 which
already happened at one 70 is down here.
They were talking what year is this?
Is this is at the end of last year.
Interesting.
Now know before I used to walk around at
one 80 or 85 and now I'm walking around
at one 70 and it's very different than it.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Then before when I was heavy,
I'm getting to work more and more that.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Once 70 he said,
I'm getting to work more and more.
Getting light,
but I really have to be
on top of my weight now.
So she's decided to stay on top of her
weight so she doesn't have to go through
so much of a brutal cut,
which I think is very wise.
One 70 is still a lot of weight.
That's 25 pounds.
She fights at one 45 she's
the 145 pound champion,
which means even right now she's
saying she doesn't cut as much,
but she cuts 25 pounds.
Man.
That's how,
how big she is for the division.
And I did Lockhart tips.
Maybe it was dolce is one of those,
wait,
come in.
Which we're saying that it's tougher
for females that the weight cut gets
tougher and tougher because the adipose
tissue and stuff like that and their
hormones.
Yeah,
I think that was Lockhart.
I don't,
I don't remember.
I just be bro Science right now
we are pro science and all that,
but I don't,
one of us know Jack Shit
about fat content thing,
especially when it comes to women.
But I do think that,
um,
you know,
there's also unique struggles with women
when it's different times of the month.
You know,
women get bloated,
they retained water,
and sometimes it's hard
to get that water out.
I have also talked to some women I've
dated in the past when and who do those
who cut
weight to not for fighting,
but for like bodybuilding
where they do bikini,
right?
Her thyroids are fucked up
so then their body cut down,
but then it goes,
oh shit,
we don't do that again.
So it blows up and it's
trying to protect stuff.
So weight cutting for women,
the high Maffra time
gets tougher and tougher.
Row Science Hashtag Bro Science
ProSites bad for everybody,
man.
It's not good for anybody.
That's why cowboy at 70 I
like is 55 or so drawn out.
But then there's guys like
fucking till till you know,
Wonderboy is fucking huge to like,
dude,
you know what we're about.
He shorter but he's fucking thick,
Mick and scary and he
swings to try to kill you.
Here's the thing that scares me
about this fight with cowboy cal.
We needs this,
right?
He's a bit of a fork in
the road for first career.
He's fighting a guy and Mike
Perry who's trained with his camp,
nobody knows cowboy better watch cab.
We sparred more than people at Jackson's.
Yeah.
And can we needs this then there's the
whole thing with Mike [inaudible] and
John who's corner and
Perry against cowboy.
Just a shit situation man.
But it is for everybody.
Just highly charged.
It's highly charged.
But look,
both guys are there.
They're,
it's a matchup that people want to say.
You know,
it's,
it's a real crossroads match off.
I love the fight.
It's a crossroads match up because if
a pirate Perry can't get past Robin or
can't get past a Donald's Roney and
it puts him in this position where,
you know,
he's,
um,
he's learning,
he's certainly getting better,
but when it comes to
world class competition,
who's the most world class guy he's faced,
but before it's Felder and fell just
really a 155 pounds daughters is best.
When he mentioned he was
hurt before that Potts,
he lost.
He lost that.
That's an old Jake Ellenberger.
Unfortunately,
but it's still fucking stunning
the way he knocked him out.
You realize that that kind of
older Jake Ellenberger for sure,
but that elbow on the break
was legit as fuck dude.
Cause then when you look at the guys,
Alan Jobe and beat him,
right?
So yeah,
it should be by if this is
by far the toughest fight.
I think this is his toughest fight,
but also they know each other.
They've sparred together and um,
I think that,
but you know what?
I liked those.
Sorry.
I think Donald thinks he
knows his tendencies and he
knows what he can do with
them.
And um,
you know,
I think Donald has some
good times with them.
They say when they grappled
Donald tuned him up.
That's what I think Matt.
And that's one of the things that Mike
Perry sad is that Donald's probably going
to try to grab a hold of
me and put me on my back.
I'm holding me down.
You know,
it's,
you can't,
you can't discount this dude.
I mean,
he knocked out Matt Brown.
this fucking combination that he did
to Rick story was preposterous to
capitalism.
One of the great that he's
just been doing it for a long,
long fucking time.
And the way he did that Rick story went,
dude,
he's just touching him up.
He's a touch scary thing about Donald's.
When Donald can be the bully,
he's gonna fuck you up.
But when someone draws a line in the
sand and starts going forward on Donald,
he struggles a little bit.
Ideas fight.
You know there,
there's some,
the guys who don't play his games,
Matt Brown,
that was a tough fight for him.
So he knocked him out.
That was a tough fucking fight.
What was it,
Matt Brown's tough fight for anybody.
Watch this.
Here it is.
Here's that elbow boom son.
I mean,
he's got some fucking power,
man.
He,
he looked great against filter.
He really did.
He did.
He didn't just look great
because fell to hurt his arm.
He looked great because he looked great,
but felt he did hurt his arm.
But I mean,
he took his arm off Mike Perry's head,
that spinning back fist
leads to so many broken arms.
Think about it.
There's a lot of God.
Yeah,
you hit that forehead and Felder and I
were talking about it like he was like,
he's tries to kind of smash it with a,
like a hammer fist.
You know,
you try to catch a guy like
right at the end of it,
like sometimes,
sometimes.
And sometimes you hit
that fucking forehead.
Foreheads are so hard,
man.
Maybe it's a blessing in disguise.
Cause Felder's a great commentator so
do that and quick and punch in the face.
Um,
he is a great commentator.
He's very,
very good spin together,
man.
I was like,
damn,
this dude is smooth and professional.
He loves the sport.
He really does love the sport.
You know,
he's an acting major.
Theater majors.
Yeah,
he was a theater major,
a smart guy.
He's very good at it.
But do it for the two.
Your fucking,
he likes fighting.
Of course he likes it.
He's finding James Vick next,
which is a thing.
It's a very good fight.
James Vick is,
I'll fucking big guy.
His last one,
like his first big step up
for James Vick lost that.
But James Vick and Paul
Felder's a great fight.
That's a great fight to crazy fight.
Right?
Isn't it pretty crazy fight.
Yeah.
I mean the big fight for James Vick,
but well it's a big fight for both guys
fell this just coming off a loss and the
loss was like a last minute fight.
I mean,
I that's right.
I think you only got like a couple
of weeks they switched it on.
Yeah.
Less than that.
Right.
And he moved up to one 70 for that fight
instead of fighting at one 55 which,
you know,
uh,
I think if you're going to fight a
weight class above yours and you know,
you feel like it's the time
and you made the decision,
that's great,
you should do that.
But if you're not doing that,
if you plan to keep fighting at one
55 to take a fight in a larger way,
class is a big risk.
And it take a fight against apple up.
Yeah.
Against a real killer.
Like Perry,
I think it's super dangerous.
He's dangerous because he
hits like a seven year.
There's guys who were to take hates it,
but he couldn't hit like
a fucking middleweight.
Even.
He hits fucking hard to real problems
and he takes it and you got to remember
cowboy has fought everybody.
Man.
He's fought so many fucking people,
you know.
And this is named MMA fighter.
He's probably fine,
man.
Ever met.
And this is deep into his career.
You know,
this is a real,
like Darren till is a young,
enormous welterweight
and cowboy lost to him.
It's like damn,
how good is Darren till
Kelby lost Edwards too.
But if k to Leon Leon Edwards,
that's right.
He lost a decision decision.
That was the one we,
he was sick as fuck though.
And he almost pulled out of the fight.
Still true.
It's true.
No doubt.
Look,
no one's saying,
I'm not saying that this isn't a monster.
No one's saying cowboys,
a 20 year old guy who's at
the beginning of his career,
he's been fighting a long time.
But I think you get a look at
a person from their last fight.
And you go,
ah man,
he slept and like,
are you sure?
Are you sure?
Because he,
he might just be unmotivated or a lack
having a lack of discipline for this camp
or just find a really fucking good guy.
And Edward at 10 Darren till yes.
Terrible.
Matchups farm until his win
was against the other cowboy,
the Brazilian Calloway,
right?
Yeah.
And Darrin tells such if
he asks him and Daryl,
sorry,
Yancey materials,
you can't keep him off you if you
can't clip him and keep you up to you.
Yeah.
He's a nightmare.
Fat Best One of the best in the world.
And this is one of the
things that highlights how
underrated Woodley strikings
become because Woodley
knocked down both till,
who started to be one of the best strikers
in the division and long and awkward
and Wonderboy knocked dumb luck,
choked him out,
but not down Wonderboy in bolts of
their fights and had them all fucked up.
Whereas neither one of
those guys hurt him.
Neither one of those guys hit him.
That's kind of crazy impressive too.
And doing rap albums and shit,
I didn't hurt.
Here's rap.
However,
was it good?
Was Khalifa?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
for sure.
Have you heard of?
To me?
No,
it's not bad.
You know,
he got upset that we were talking
about cm punk and I was saying that,
uh,
that cm,
that,
that what does that Logan,
Paul Logan,
Paul character,
the guy.
You're right about that.
Is that what you said?
Yes.
I said
why?
Because Logan Paul wrestling
high school cm punk did not also,
I was looking at his boxing match.
I was looking the way
chains punches together.
He can,
he's athletic.
Yeah,
he could punch.
So if you're in allow cm punk,
the fight in the UFC,
that was on my own.
That was all my point was my
point wasn't the cm punk is bad.
And I think that cm punk is
actually a very brave guy.
I think he's,
that's a powerful thing to do,
to take a chance.
I can publicly,
yeah,
how dare you.
But I mean anyone's brain
talking shit about him,
but I'm most certainly not.
No,
he's a teammate.
It's awesome.
I get it.
He loves TMZ show,
SAT,
gets ratings to Willie,
knows how to play the game.
I'm thinking he loves the guy too,
which I respect.
And if you go,
Hey Logan,
Paul can beat up your boy.
I don't even know if he could.
I don't know if they're even the same way.
Tony fucking a lot bigger.
I have no idea how big it Logan Paul,
he's the Youtuber,
so I don't know.
Like someone said,
he fought at 185 pounds
and his boxing match,
but they cut any weight though,
right?
It's he that pig when 85 he's a big fella.
His,
he has a little brother too.
He's calling out like Dell,
Dylan Dannis,
which is silly.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
And then he goes out when people go,
ah,
you know,
Dylan's a worldclass just the guy goes,
no,
not Jujitsu.
Just box it.
It's good.
Yeah.
He just doesn't know.
Oh Shit.
It's about to go down,
dude.
Mike Perry is in the cage
and cowboys walking that boy,
you always look so nervous
when he fights in Denver.
He was 86 kilograms flat,
whatever that is.
86 kilograms.
What is that?
Is that a hundred that's 160 something,
right?
I don't know.
I a twice one 89.5 so he's way bigger
than cm punk will see you playing cause
pilot 70 cut weight.
Those guys didn't cut.
Well he might be cm park might
be in the one eight nine range.
Logan Paul definitely is.
Why the ground?
Paul is a fighter and 70 yeah.
There's nothing wrong saying that.
He probably weighs like probably one 80
or something because Santa one seven if
you had a guest,
cm punk Adh.
What is 91 92 I believe that.
So it's WWE.
It's 20 pounds.
Probably not.
Probably actually now it's
probably UFC information.
Yeah.
What are your fights out?
Well,
does he competes?
He might be cutting weight from
one 90 which is not outrageous.
So Logan Paul's way younger,
little lot younger.
Vibrant.
Well,
it's more,
you know,
it's one thing if it was Melvin
Manhoef fit 36 you know a guy.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like it's not just being
36 it's learning later in life.
You know there's a thing about striking
if you're not an explosive person and
you learned later in life,
man,
it seems like it's really difficult.
The people that seem to pick it up or
people had a little bit of it when they
were younger,
like a little bit of karate,
little bit of boxing,
and they kind of kept the understanding
of their head and then as they retire
from other sports,
then they start to do it.
Was that the case with you?
A little bit?
A little bit.
Did you,
were you doing any amateur boxing matches
or anything like that while you were
doing football before
you're doing football?
I was doing some Jujitsu.
Jujitsu.
When did you like get
heavily into striking?
Mm,
I would do it to stay in shape during
the football season was before the
ultimate final for the ultimate.
How much,
how much striking had you done?
A just a golden gloves,
but I had six months of training.
Six months.
Six months of bucks and yeah,
see like now think about,
Whoa,
look at this Mike Perry.
And facing them bowed to him.
Let me that mean face.
He's,
he looks like almost like,
uh,
like,
like a,
a devil type character in a movie he
looks like under Laski miniature size
heading mean.
So mean.
He looks,
he looks,
he's probably one of the meanest
looking dudes in the spores.
It,
he's intense look and dude,
so mean looking.
Yeah.
He's becoming more and
more comfortable to,
you know,
that's what you're seeing from him now
to this is this so much pressure on the
cow.
Much measure.
I just so much I liked my pay,
but copies of personal friends.
I'm rooting for cowboy.
I feel exactly the same way.
I uh,
I'm,
I love watching frank with cowboy,
but I love Mike Perry to easily look,
no matter what happens,
we're going to see a hell
of a fight right now.
Hopefully.
Look,
I like cowboys do haircuts on,
I'm not mad at it.
Kind of a little crazy.
Shaved on the sides.
Right.
And Patch on the Tuck is Baird.
Yeah.
It looks like a savage,
you know cowboys,
grandma's low savage in this fight.
You know you're fighting a savage.
You better look savage
to match the savage.
Here we go.
Look at these two.
Whew.
I know.
Me Too.
I'm a terrible bite to make me nervous.
Have a super angry.
Yeah,
he does.
You think cowboy flips off
a Winkeljohn three wins.
I don't know if he does.
Let's say hey had kicked kv.
Maybe there might be.
So that's cowboy dude or something.
Since I've known cowboys hate Winkeljohn
and that'd be something to it.
Let's see what happens here.
Damn.
He looks disciplined.
Look at Mike Perez striking hands up.
High light on the fool.
Shit.
He trying to knock them out
big right hand you the cowboys.
A slow starter.
So if,
if I'm Mike Paris coach,
I know Greg to the elbow
off the brake cowboy.
He's fucking good in the clinch Dell.
Damn.
Let's see here.
Well that's the thing about cowboy,
surprisingly good wrestling.
He fucks people up.
The Dude,
I've seen him fucking amazing forgetful
and they forget because he's got picked
that he does here.
That's amazing.
He lifts his left arm and
me picks dudes all the time.
Well,
he also like,
he's been,
that does a nice knee to the body.
That shit was sharp.
I'll cowboy sit trade with you all day.
But Paris,
and he was very good as well though.
But um,
see the thing about cowboy is he's like a,
he seems like a fun guy,
right?
He's always partying in and
driving around in his jet skiing,
getting wild and jumped on
a plane and all that stuff.
So people think,
oh,
this guy is just wild.
He's also a seriously skilled fighter.
God,
a lot of that is a little
bit of a smokescreen.
He's a,
he's an absolutely an adrenaline junkie,
but he's a very skilled fighter.
It looks unprofessional inside leg kick.
Just lit up that enzyme.
And you do it from all angles.
Yeah.
And he'll look.
Has he had some rough fights?
Yeah.
Against the best in the world though.
You're going to get that this is a
crazy ass fucking sport he's doing.
It also has over 45 exactly.
And you're throwing bones at
each other at a high velocity.
You're going to get some knockouts.
You're going to give some,
you're going to get some,
it's just part of the program.
But cowboy look at that good head
room with their cowboys still here.
Do you feel African?
Because callow Tim,
he's biting his mouthpiece and just
going forward cause cowboys fucking tall.
I thought Perry was a
lot shorter compared.
He's fucking bitch.
I think he's six feet tall.
Jesus tank too,
man.
He's a tank.
He's a real thick dude man.
When you stub his girl in
his corner and he lost,
he's like,
you don't what?
Pregnant anymore,
Huh?
Well you know he was on campus hat off.
He can't make 55 fuck cal cal cowboy,
Ken.
God,
it's stuff on Kelly as he gets older too.
Yeah.
I mean maybe Perry can
make 55 maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe you can kill himself and get
to like rumble Johnson used to do.
He looks great at 70 dam
that will help her get up,
get the fucking scared.
It's good.
But he's doing it on the outside and
Donald's slipping away from it now.
They sparred a lot,
a lot before they did a lot of sparring
with walking kind of fucked up.
I,
it's like when I filed a hundred
Laski we sparked a bunch together.
So when we fought you're super tender
cause you knew what the guy was good at so
you wouldn't throw your normal shit.
So it makes for a more boring fight.
Sometimes in cowboys side though,
I think psychologically it probably helps
him cause he's already fought this guy
before and if he did get the
better of him been training,
it doesn't mean you're dealing
with the same Mike Perry.
I'm sure Mike Perry is way better now.
But if they did train together and
cowboy did get the best of them,
then that shit's probably on
both of their minds right now.
There's just no way it's not.
And that's a psychological
edge that cowboy would like.
Dude,
Oh side can travel is nasty off his past.
He reminds me a lot of Anthony Pettis
off his back where they're so explosive.
Even if you know what triangles come in,
there's fucking the really,
really sneaky man.
Well,
let's see,
because I can see those can
be tough to do anything.
This is not somewhere he wants to be.
Let's see how he gets
out of this stuff is,
I don't think it will take this all day.
Oh,
that was beautiful.
Yeah.
I encourage the tape.
Oh my God.
That was beautiful.
Smash him.
He can go to mount though.
But this is the thing that Mike Perry was
saying that he would do that to him in
the gym and cowboys doing
it to him right now.
She cowboys super confident here.
Cal with grappling.
Phenomenal.
It's phenomenal.
But not only got that look,
trap,
that arm,
he's being sock him in the fucking face.
Torture in this guy for years.
Right?
Or for,
well,
not years.
Maybe a few weeks,
a couple of weeks,
maybe a few.
Sudanese.
He has him crucified.
Right.
Years.
I made that up,
but he couldn't.
When he is doing though is exercising
some serious confidence in [inaudible].
See this?
Look it.
He lost it though.
He lost a position.
He lost it.
He's on his back.
So this isn't a path for cowboy?
No.
Oh,
great.
Has a great guard,
man.
It seems pretty good so far.
Yeah.
No,
he's got his guard attacking and he's,
he looks like he's trying to
bait them with the right arm.
Cowboys,
triangles.
Fucking filthy man.
How needed the ass pipe?
Where are you allowed to hit back,
back there,
everything.
Anything goes.
Anything but the zones
hit the scroll them.
But you're kinda hitting
super closest snack.
It's like you're hitting this tastes
like the house next door to you getting
bombed on.
Look at this.
Armbar attempt always spikes him
and he's gonna break his arm.
He's got to host breaking his arm.
Done it.
No,
he's passing over and he's passing over.
Oh,
cowboys breaking his fucking arm.
Fuck yeah.
That's a wrap son.
Cowboy.
Do y'all take him?
Show him with that is for cowboy.
Didn't take a shot and got an arm bar.
Didn't take a big shot.
[inaudible] book.
I like to come at me,
mother fucker.
I love it.
This,
leave this talking,
all that shit.
You gotta appreciate it man.
Dude,
you get kicked out of your own gym.
Here comes this kid too.
And just had a baby boy.
I don't think that's what he's
doing on his wife to bring his kid,
his kid.
That's tall,
man.
That's what it,
that's phenomenal.
It wasn't an anger thing.
That's phenomenal.
That was,
he wants to sign a damn man.
Oh,
what a cute little fella.
Wow,
dude.
How happy sockeye.
Wow.
What a great frickin wind for cowboy.
He looks so confident,
Dude.
Look how confident he looked and I think
some of that is just to not just that
he's a really good fighter,
but also that they've,
they've sparked their familiar.
We had a number.
He knew he had it.
If it went to the ground,
especially dude,
but he has no god.
That is cute.
Standing up.
He didn't get hit with it.
No.
Yeah,
he's moving to it.
He looks smooth as fuck.
He looked super polished standing up.
What a big win for cal,
but he looks like he's got
to snap his fucking arm to,
hey man,
he might've broke it.
We don't even know.
I mean,
he was always bad English.
Please.
God Man,
very underrated.
Get spiked to trap the leg.
Nope.
Spiking holds ever works
unless you rampage.
I say 80 doesn't let go,
turns him and then holds them belly down,
gets that arm and now when
he arches his back up like,
dude,
there's a,
there's a ton of fucking torque.
Look at this.
That arm is in trouble and it's,
we get cowboy sideways.
It might've been examined right there,
dude.
His arm might've went sideways.
Look at this again.
Look at this from this angle.
Like look at where the arm is.
He was our intern.
Yeah,
look at where his arm is though
is it's almost like he's doing it.
He's getting it like this
way and Torque in it.
Yeah,
he's gay way joint manipulation
and he's not getting it like this.
It looked like he wasn't getting it
like this straightened out my grade.
Like to the side.
It looked like it was almost like this.
That will rip your shit apart,
man.
That's tremendous.
Ooh,
big way again,
this nothing I liked Mike Perry
has nothing to do with like I do.
I just know taboos career,
what he's been through.
He had a baby,
he gets kid kicked out of his gym,
his back's against the wall,
he loses this one.
Everyone's telling him to retire
like it's fucking Donald Cerrone,
man.
Look,
God damn good too.
And the fact that he
came to them and said,
hey,
I don't think it's fair that
you guys train this guy,
you know,
which doesn't make any sense.
We've been,
we've been together forever.
And they said,
okay,
well we're going to talk it
through and have a meeting.
And then they come back after the meeting.
Oh yeah,
I'm going to train him.
You can't come here anymore.
So fucked up.
And then,
but also would have him win the,
the interesting thing too is,
you know cowboy Daigo is Greg Jackson
and according to next week he goes,
yeah,
just not this one to just see this shit.
The movie,
like what is it called?
Overlord dude.
This shit looks so good.
Seeing tons of people talk about it today.
I said,
it's really good.
Oh,
is it out already this weekend?
Oh my God,
a video game right now.
I don't think it hasn't.
I think so.
Dude.
Am I crazy?
I'm thinking of Wolfenstein definitely
could have been a video game.
Fuck yeah,
it might be a bit of good.
I'm still,
if it's not,
they fucked up.
I remember that time.
Make it a video game with the release.
I know people would play
the shit out of that.
I was balls deep in Wolfenstein.
As a kid,
imagine what has to come into
place to make a video game.
Like imagine if you
have a movie and you go,
man,
we've got to make a video
game to get this movie.
Like to come out with it.
It'd be the perfect video game.
What is it?
Overlord film review.
Great video game movie that's
not based on a video game.
That's funny.
I figured it was the video game.
The name overlord.
The poster looks like two fucking
Wolfenstein so ridiculously fun.
That's funny.
That's so funny.
It hurts my feelings.
Yeah,
man.
That's what it seemed like.
It seemed like a video game.
A hundred percent dude,
look at cowboy.
He's so happy.
How can you not be your son's?
They're chewing on monster
can shout out the monster.
Don't let the sun actually
get that monster system.
Yeah.
Now that would not be a match and that
he gets a hold of that and that's open
to,
and it looks like a all's good in the end.
Wow.
Beautiful.
No,
no,
no.
That's okay.
I'll say hi to.
I want to see him and congratulate him.
He's an awesome dude.
What up in his hometown,
man.
So happy for him.
That was a stressful.
Here's the thing though,
man.
He looked good.
His fuck.
It wasn't just that he won,
dude.
He look smooth.
How about Paul Felder
trains at Jackson's too.
He knows what's going on.
Most one with history.
Paul's with Duke.
He was at Jackson's first.
Yeah,
before that.
Before Duke did.
He loves Duke.
Okay.
That powerful Joe Schilling,
his grandma's shaking man.
Macdonald.
How cool it.
Your son's so happy.
Look how fucking happy he is.
Look at that fucking animal.
Love it.
I wonder what Kelly's love it.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a guy that like,
man,
look at that resume.
Cowboy Hall of Famer Man.
Yeah,
a hundred percent yeah.
He's got some big fights.
One big fights,
but most finishes in UFC history.
Most wins in UFC history.
You're a hall of Famer.
Yeah.
Even if he never wins a title,
he's a hall of Famer.
I agree.
He's the one guy.
I think he passes your eyes.
The one guy who never went to title.
That shit becomes more popular too.
Yeah.
Well you're right.
You know your eyes when thinking
about getting back in there.
No Games,
pasture board,
man.
He has so much shit.
You don't shut a movies healing
up and he's thinking about it.
Oh,
that's about it.
Yeah.
How about the ditch?
The fly?
This is super impressive man.
But cowboy did super impressive
that he never let it go.
Like that was tight as shit.
Dude slamming it's old school,
but yeah.
Yeah,
but it's the way in the
transitions are sure to stay on it.
Yeah.
Because even when Mike was doing the
right thing by passing over the top,
it looked like he was almost out.
But the risk control that he had the
cowboy hat and it keeping it in the
position where he wanted it,
the squeeze.
I think there's a,
like again,
him and Anthony Pettis are guys when it
goes to the ground because people think
of a miss knockout artist,
which they are and the great standing.
But Anthony Pettis and him on the ground
are fucking tricky man from their back.
Most people aren't from their back,
but Petterson him from
their back is nasty.
They both,
they both dive on shit real quick too.
Explosive Man.
Yeah.
Well they basic stuff,
but it's explosive.
Cowboys started off with Moy.
Tai.
Look at this.
Yeah.
A quick though.
This.
I was so pretty.
[inaudible]
boom.
The slam and tightening.
Look how's it's to see that.
Oh look how he's got that.
Like trapped in like that.
Yo,
he's fucking that elbow up.
Yeah.
There was gonna be sore tomorrow.
Oh,
he had a tap like you were saying.
It's a tough loss for Mike Perry
because you want to see where he's at.
Right.
Cause the,
the guys that he's beat,
you do see where he's at though?
Donald's a step ahead of him.
At least.
At least a step.
Maybe more.
Yes.
You know Mike,
but Mike Perry looked better than he's
ever looked before and he's just fighting
the guy who was the best
guys ever fought before.
And when he,
Mike Perry moves in,
he moves in with his hands up high.
His Chin's talk his techniques on point.
He look,
he's not done.
He's not done.
I don't even mean in his career.
I mean it's progress is going to get,
he just got to Jackson
already from a beating.
Paul Felder.
Keeman looked better in a,
in as a fighter against cowboy.
So the next one,
maybe you just don't give them,
uh,
the caliber of cowboy.
He's not there yet.
Well,
can you get there though?
Sleep on cowboy,
man.
They forget.
They think for some reason he's done,
but just because he got knocked out by
Darren till and then lost Leon Roberts.
Leon Roberts is a really good fighter.
And he was a Roberts or Edwards.
Did I say Edwards or Robert?
I don't know.
Now I'm getting to weed.
It is Edwards,
right?
It's Edwards.
Right?
Leon Roberts or Edwards had
fought cowboy cowboys last fight.
Edwards.
Did I say,
I said Roberts.
It's all good to Tibet.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I got a contact high
dude doing sober October.
Did you get fucked up right away after?
Sorry to Leon Edwards.
Um,
but my point was yeah,
we got fucked up big time
to get more fucked up now,
which took 30 days off.
I don't think so.
It seems exactly the same.
You on no nut November now?
Uh,
no.
It's supposed to be no,
remember November?
No,
it's no,
not November maybe.
And your weird camp.
My fucking hell.
Oh.
Can we get together?
There was no,
no,
no.
We're trying to get rid of these loads.
Yeah.
Less loads.
December.
I remember hearing about tantric sex.
Tantric sex makes sex better and oh,
what is this crazy commercial people
to drive it wrapped or though,
look at that.
Forrest Griffin still
doing the damn thing,
dude.
How bout uh,
TJ verse.
So Hutto but at 25 foot doesn't make sense
that it's going to be at 25 is really
going to get rid of the
flyweight division there.
Done.
That seems strange.
Why do it?
I know why.
When sue who don't come up,
because I guess Tj wants
to be a double champion.
That's the last fight.
But it's a for a belt that's for
divisions not around anymore.
Well,
maybe they decided to do it because
the historical implications,
because if Tj can drop down and beat him,
he's the last champ champ.
And he wins the title in two divisions.
Unless he wants to go up to 45 you know?
And then if he does,
I mean maybe he builds up after a while
and goes up to 45 for a few fights,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I mean,
you've got a whole lot for him.
Well,
well,
there's some good fights for it.
45 for sure.
Not 45 45 seat may a tough one for him.
It's going to be tough.
35 there's still some fights.
Marlin Mariah's is right there.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
Jimmy Rivera,
just one is last one.
E five is his natural way class.
But if he's working with that,
what's that guy's name?
What is his name?
Alameda.
Is that his name?
I forget what his,
uh,
he's marshaling Tj Dillashaw.
Jamie searching for it.
He's got it in the
God it I hate when that marijuana
clouds my memory and ruins my argument.
And I have marijuana.
They have no excuse.
You got hotbox on.
Oh there we go.
Yeah,
I'm contact I this stuff a
strong second hand smoke.
Um,
but TJ versa,
who does a good fight though?
It's a very good fight.
Can't find his strength and conditioning
coach didn't pop up right away.
It's all good.
Sam Calavaro Kalvia yeah,
that's right.
What did I say?
[inaudible]
do you know why?
Cause he's a comic named France Alameda.
That's why.
Hmm.
So spell it.
K a.
L A.
V.
I t.
T.
A cal Alito.
Calla veto.
Tell veto
the grip.
Gj raves about this guy.
I know
his name because he didn't
want to get out on the podcast.
He goes,
I don't want anyone working with them.
And I can say his name like,
dude,
come on.
He's hilarious.
That's interesting.
But probably accurate.
Yeah,
that's probably accurate.
You find out about a scientist out there
that's just doing it for the art gives
you a huge advantage.
Yeah.
I mean this guy seems like he knows so
now lunch now or him and Tj have that.
They went on that Jim Munios.
It's him.
Right?
And then they'll Scott in Pico there.
That little fucking monster.
Yeah,
Aaron Picos terrifying.
Oh my God.
That left hook that he killed that dude
with the biggest prospect and it was
like,
oh,
shovel hook like a left upper cut.
His body shots nasty.
But that one to the chin where just to
do just was out cold and just fell back
like Jesus.
It was like he takes shots,
he just doesn't respect his opponents
cause he fucks up worldclass guys all the
time in the gym.
So when they give them like,
oh,
here's layer,
he's foreign.
Oh.
He's like,
fuck that Larry.
And just walk forward.
It's what they see in the gym.
Eat some of the best guys in the world.
He started them.
Boom.
That is such a nasty hook,
man.
It's so perfectly placed
under the right arm.
Look at that dude.
That is crazy.
That was my time.
That from the beginning,
the cows slick.
This is like this.
He sees the righthand comment,
any hooks under it and right on the
Chin and there's slides and we're doing
right by him because they're not
throwing them to the wolves right away.
You're like,
if he's in the UFC,
he'd be fighting fucking
top 10 guys right away.
Look at that nasty left hook to
the fucking liver right there.
Two guys out to the body now.
Oh Man.
Liver shots are horrific.
Nothing really might be
worse than him knocked out.
Yeah.
There's literally nothing you can do.
Kids at tank too and it's
super high level wrestler,
wrestler and boxer.
Yeah.
Some list.
As long he's been wrestling,
he can do it all.
Thinking about this Freddy Roach,
his corner to MMA fighters,
him and GSP.
So there must be something special
about that fucking kid dam.
And uh,
you know,
I'd like the story that
he lost his first fight.
I liked that I was hyping up so
much on I working with flight,
but that's a,
that's a a cold hard reminder.
We'll ask.
Got Coke.
Can I go?
Why would you give them that
big fucking duty goes Brennan.
We asked guys,
you would know vets and
they would not fight him.
He was like,
there's like this mythical
fucking or about this kid.
No one wants to fund this.
The only guy we get fine.
Wow.
Was a terrible match for me.
It's fucking seven and eight.
Oh big or bigger guy.
Two weight classes up is a bad idea.
Not so picos never fought before
and fight that mass square garden.
His first fight,
I didn't know the main car.
How much bigger than him.
I just thought the guy just
caught him with a shot.
He's a lot bigger.
A lot bigger dude.
Bad idea.
What did,
what did the guy weigh in at?
I mean they weighed in the same,
but he's,
you know,
he,
his original weight classes higher up.
Yeah,
he's a bigger fighter,
but they just thought
anyone was so special.
He'd fucking starch him.
Well,
it didn't.
The dude have a marginal record.
Look,
he'd only fought them to know once.
He really pretty sure
it's seven to no damn.
Yeah,
he goes o and L.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
I was like,
cause I asked coker,
you know who's great?
And I go,
why the fuck would you,
I guess Brennan's only guy
who would take this fight.
Wow.
I guess he knew something.
Yeah.
I guess.
What's homeboy's name?
Who he lost to?
Yeah,
I forget,
but it's crazy.
What's that,
Zach?
That's right.
Exactly.
He's seven to know,
right?
It's probably eight.
No,
no.
Unless he lost one since then.
That was a while ago.
No,
he's nine and three now.
Yeah,
he's lost.
Wow.
Pull up the map the
thing so we could see it.
Two losses before he fought on Pico.
So what was his record?
We fought Pico.
Oh,
here we go.
I must have been eight and two.
So a lot of evidence to the a wad.
That guy's fucking good.
But still when he fought Piquillo
seven and two so nine fights.
That's a shitload for guys.
Zero to get sky was,
oh no,
it was my point.
You fucking nuts man.
And you know,
fighting in Madison
Square Garden first debut,
you know you only get one debut.
It's a big deal.
And you're young pressure on TV.
Everyone knows how good you are and the
other guy's good and he got some Dick
head in a suit and tie in the box.
And you're the next
Lebron James or the MMA.
His name's Brendan.
Yeah,
they just just fill your sim out.
Could they just take your button?
Go.
I still believe it though.
Yeah,
like a balloon.
So you receive Franco Columbo,
make a hot water bottle
explode but below it into it.
No,
that's what people are doing.
It is.
But it's cool that low and smoke depot.
I was one of those guys
made to stand by it.
But he was right.
You were right.
He just,
it was a lesson and it's just part of
being a human being in competition and
look at Franco Columbo
checked just he would,
who would blow up a hot water bottle.
That's how strong his fucking
lunch until we would explode.
Holy Shit.
Look at me.
People are watching that bull.
This lady's like,
Oh my God,
I can't believe it.
Do you not fucking strong.
Your lungs have to be to make this happen.
Like look at them.
He thing you know you have
nothing else going on.
Are you attending this live?
That guy is a tank of a human.
That's some old school,
Italian neanderthal genes,
some old school entertainment.
God,
look at those diamond pieces.
I bet that hot chick.
Come on.
Do it.
That's the Arnold set dude.
Where Jack,
Why watch pumping iron?
I get sad that I wasn't back
then hanging out with them.
They looked like they
were just doing steroids.
Fucking girls.
We'd Venice beach.
Jack wasn't all the bums are one.
They're just lifting every day.
It's fucking gold.
Just getting jacked.
Yeah,
that's all he cared about.
Jackson pages and probably like at
a level that nobody had done before.
The steroids right along and all
of a sudden the party got started.
Like you look at it free when
they're hanging out with,
you know what I got to tell you though?
Here's what's weird.
If you look at Arnold right there,
he was Mister Olympia.
Obviously jacked as fuck but beautiful.
Nowhere near as he Coleman is.
Any of the big guys that you see today
we're talking about different steroids.
Well,
it's nice.
See h came along and steroids and it's
not just that it's they just want to
continue to get bigger,
like there should really be a time and
it's hard to figure out when that time is
where you really don't
want to get any bigger.
He just want to get more sculpted
and more ripped and more dif.
You want to get more proportionate.
Well so that everything looks right,
whether it's your calves or
your like [inaudible] shit.
That's why the same Ronnie
Coleman kind of fucked exam.
Frank.
Yeah.
They used to love Frank Zane even
though he was smaller than those guys.
Wheeler.
Yeah.
Unbelievable symmetry.
They said Ronnie Coleman
came along and was like,
oh,
cool story and just was like cash and
they said he's just fucked everything up
because he's so massive.
Even before him,
Dorian Yates,
Dorian Yates was a Dji aunt.
The mother fucker was hugely tall.
No shorter.
See,
Ronnie was tall.
Yeah,
that's true.
Color for a bodybuilder.
I want to say he's taller than me.
Dorian's taller than me,
but I don't pick the peas.
I don't think he's six feet tall,
maybe six feet tall.
But anyway,
in his prime,
he was safe.
I mean,
mass talked to Ronnie Coleman,
massive.
He was pretty fucking big man.
Ever.
See Dorian Yates is prime.
She's picture at Gold's.
I don't know enough to say that.
Who was the first guy to
gets super jacked like that?
But he was the first Mr Olympia
that I remember seeing going,
well,
what the fuck?
Kind of steroids.
And they use it now and he talked about,
he's like super open
about it's full cycle.
Oh really?
Took,
Oh yeah man,
he did my pocket jacks.
He's the best.
Have you seen the Ronnie
Coleman doc on Netflix?
Haven't I heard?
It's awesome.
It above me out in a boat out and go,
you know what?
I've never squat and a heavy ever
again or his back is destroyed.
Right?
Two hip replacements back's fucked and
he has to have crutches and he's like in
constant pain now.
Constant been taken
fucking opiates every day.
Didn't he have like,
bummer.
Multiple back surgeries,
multiple back surgeries,
fused pinched nerves.
Damn.
Look at Dory and now it's like me now.
He looks at him there.
Yeah.
Dude,
he was Jack's shaggy city.
Ain't got Sham Ronnie though.
See Him on stage though.
That's a picture.
He was bigger than that.
Then we'll get to the far left.
The far left up there.
Look at this size of that
mother Pharma's thickie.
Dude,
look at the size of him.
He was fucking huge man and
shredded and just want to pick.
He was worked harder than Alabamians.
Huge.
They were all on the steroids for sure.
For sure.
Them steroids.
They were all on all the steroids,
but for sure that motherfucker worked
as hard if not harder than lifting
weights.
Phil Heath was Jack to,
okay,
here's the question.
He's lost his last competition.
We'll look at this.
Look at those two.
How do you decide which one is more jack?
That is insane to me.
That don't make any sense.
I look at those two and I go,
wow,
and you have to have an eye for it,
right thing.
You're a jeweler.
You got to go over that
shit with jewelers glass.
Look for cut color clarity and the tube.
Karen thrills.
Real.
Look at this to be an expert.
What the fuck to the greatest backs in
history is that is that is that they'll
take Ronnie,
Ronnie Coleman on the top
left or was that Phil?
That's during Ronney Colon.
Ronnie Coleman's ass is out of control.
W but do you saying it's a Phil Heath?
I think that's running
Coleman tried to call.
I know Ronnie's ass.
Oh Wow.
Strong.
I know Ronnie ass.
That's a Ronnie fuck his lats look at,
they look like they're on a supermarket
shelf covered in Saran wrap it right.
It doesn't look like he has any fat to
it looks they look like ribs baby back
ribs that you put barbecue on.
It looks like he could
look at Dorian Yates.
It looks like he could pull your
head right through your back.
Like tap your head with your spinal
column attached and just pull it out like
the Moose Lake gts.
Yeah,
just leave a hole we accord.
Used to be for sure.
Here's the thing though,
during the eighth got that flat
ass compared to Ronnie flatty.
Why are you flat a white
room and I don't see that.
I saw in that picture,
that picture side by side picture plays.
It was a part of a different one.
It was a part of an article.
It was like one of these small towns.
That's Phil.
Can you back sheets?
I tried that.
It didn't work.
Did it work?
Can't you type in uh,
during the eighth verse,
Ronnie Coleman and Big
Birdie or no glutes,
glutes,
the proper term door.
How about just type in Dorian
Yates big booty or na right there.
There it is.
Come on Bro.
Okay,
but he's sucking in that in man.
Something was Poland is his back at some
of the g string and get his butt and
then Ronnie Coleman's pulling the
Jewish history hungry but is eating.
Those are the ones that ass at,
first of all,
there's no reason to
wear those shorts boys.
We get it.
We got it.
We know that you have a
senior to for asshole,
but at a certain point in time,
like your shorts are
too little to minutes.
Flat ass little,
but he's a little,
but he's on a little bike,
right?
Yeah,
no,
we get Ronnie's bucket.
Is that Ronnie?
On the right.
Does Ronnie,
so blacks and all those
loan leave at peach.
I take it back.
I take back what I said.
I can tell the difference,
but I can't though because well go.
I can't make go go larger
gang go larger again,
Ronnie.
All Day.
Ronnie's look at his lower back.
What is going on in there?
That's the same.
Yeah.
I guess they're both fucking insane.
The difference really to
me is from the waist down,
but agree.
But what?
Ronnie's legs are spread out.
Ooh.
See,
okay.
Now it's different,
but still Ronnie's legs or they're crazy,
dude.
We're talking about Ronnie's.
Look at it.
It's been who did his buttocks?
He's got extra inches of buttocks.
Ooh.
Uh,
Korean Zombie.
Just fucking look like those ACL.
Oh,
just started.
Oh Shit.
We're looking at male,
but he did have a flat ass though.
Ronnie Coleman's gonna ignore him.
His ass do know Jamie,
keep that at one.
Make it bigger.
No,
keep that up.
That last picture version.
Yeah,
find a bed.
Get them bending over Kenya.
Oh,
there you go.
That's plenty delicately.
It's ass,
dude.
That's how it's,
it's outrageous.
That's outrageous.
Let me see that last picture.
Jamie.
Oh Jesus Christ during the eighth got
that flat f this size of Ronnie Coleman's
muscles.
I do.
It's breezy.
Muscles look like he could fucking
kick through a building real thick.
His back is okay.
Here's the question.
Now.
His back's destroyed,
his hips destroyed,
his knees are destroyed.
Do you think that they
did things differently?
Do you think he said Ronnie did.
If when you ask the doctor like they have
everyone who compete against even Jay
Cutler,
they go,
dude,
we,
we were trained with Ronnie sometimes
and no one wanted to train with him cause
he would just do things
we wouldn't do like what?
Like 800 pounds squat
all the fucking time.
Listen,
Jesus,
every,
all the Bodybio say he's
the biggest freak ever.
How strong he was too.
They said he just,
the amount of work you do inside
that weight room was insane.
The crazy thing was when he was a cop,
oh yeah,
I am a genius with a beautiful leg kicks
inside and then now he's managing him,
pulled over by him for weed.
I'm like,
Bro,
line fucking more legal drugs in their
system than me with the foot to talking
about what are we talking about?
Come on dude,
let me go.
Right.
I'll be ironic.
It'd be hilarious.
That would be super ironic because that
guy's on illegal drugs like literally.
You can't get that big without them.
It's not possible.
Dude,
Jay Cutler and these interviews,
he just,
I don't know if I want to
hate on the guy did don't.
Yeah,
I'm not going to,
it's hard not to write God.
Get a couple beers in yet.
Haterade came down.
He's don't want to talk shit.
Damn.
J Co was giant to Jay Cutler.
Beat him when he's going
for a number nine right.
Well,
I never would thought Ronnie Coleman
shouldn't a done nine just stopped at
eight.
Oh,
fucking Phil Heath,
my boy Phil Heath lost the last one.
Who won the last one?
I was say Mr Olympia.
Never heard of him.
A guy who they compare to flex wheeler,
right.
He's a smallest thinner dude.
When I say thin,
I can't tell how many of these
are photo shopped or oh my God.
Wait a minute.
Is that real?
Go back to that last
picture he just picked up.
Jesus Christ.
Make that bigger.
What the fuck dude?
To get us people that are definitely
Photoshop but like that one doesn't look
like it's real.
That guy looks like a video game.
Character.
Photoshop.
Yeah,
that looks Photoshop and zombies down on
a piece in up here while we're talking
about ass.
Oh Man.
So yeah,
here was teeing off on
him just a moment ago.
Is He?
Yeah.
Dude.
Who won?
2018 Olympia.
This guy.
Oh Wow.
He's not sure it was.
You're not flex wheeler at all.
Giant ass thighs,
but it looks fine sized there dude.
His apps or blah.
It's a weird,
yeah,
they look like inside.
How come?
That's okay.
But blackface isn't,
well I think as black Joe.
Okay,
what?
He's black but everybody does that.
Or you can do that too.
I know they all do that.
You know?
Oh my God,
look at that.
Wait a minute.
Is he black?
If he's black,
why did he look so wider in that
photo when he was doing most muscular?
I don't know.
Jay,
who was those as close on that gentleman
through upper left hand corner.
Upper left hand corner
like you had before.
The image in the upper left
hand corner keeps rolling up.
Okay.
All the way up that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
He might be African American,
but he kind of,
Tina,
we should probably pay attention.
What do you think he is?
Jamie was his nationality.
I'm not talking about that guy.
That's the same guy.
The guy with the black abs.
No,
that's not him.
Is it?
Yes.
Oh,
he's,
that's what I'm saying.
I'm black.
Right?
Or if he has,
he's very light.
But what I'm saying is they are allowed
to wear that stuff that makes your skin
look dark.
So as you can see,
the muscles better.
Right?
But they get to a point
where it's literally,
it's blackface.
It's black body.
I also faced this from Egypt.
Okay,
so he's,
but he's much lighter,
more images,
more Maha Maha.
It doesn't make sense if that
one of them has an accurate,
the one that most Moscow with it,
you just put up,
if that's an accurate skin tone car.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus fucking Christ.
God,
he's huge.
God Dog.
What?
That one picture where you see his whole
body that isn't even look like a real
person.
Here's an ass on them too.
That Egyptian ass bro.
Dude,
that dude.
How mad are people that
we're talking about ass?
That's fine.
Oh,
Korean Zombie with a straight left.
He won the thing.
This dude from Egypt believe so.
Yeah.
Be beat Phil here.
That's right.
Wow.
He's a beast man.
And you know,
fucking this,
this beautiful spiritual position.
I'll look a double tap on the face,
but Green Zone,
high green just stopped doing
the Olympia because it was uh,
like rigged.
So he's like,
fuck this dude.
Yeah.
He'd be a good guy.
Get on the park.
Why they think it's rigged?
A category and always Kia.
Jesus Christ.
God Damn.
What big Ramey as EDC is his name?
Ramey.
I think so.
Yeah.
What is his full name?
We should be what?
I tried pronouncing credits.
Jostle.
Let me go back to it.
Let me try to pretty much
better at names than me.
I don't want to fuck this up.
Momma do else?
Ba?
No,
mom,
let's listen to someone say it.
It's fine.
I don't want to fuck out man.
Sounds so authentic that I feel like five
ten three hundred ten pounds contest.
Wait,
five 10 yeah,
it's me,
Fairmont son.
That's it.
Thick dude.
Especially the type of girl.
White guys,
like regular white guys.
Who was the white guy?
The big guy.
The Gunther Maryam.
He would compete with Ronnie Coleman.
Those guys?
No,
he's name is Gunther.
He was a giant Swede and you're
just like fucking colossal from X.
Men would go chocolate face.
Do they get chocolate but you can't.
Jay Cutler went chocolate j girls show
10 girls do it too and we just accept it.
Yeah,
it's full chocolate body.
It's full chocolate
body and chocolate face.
Yeah.
It's like as long as
you go full chocolate,
as long as you have tracks
and they don't give a fuck,
but you have to go everywhere.
You can't have like one side chocolate
and one side not have face trying to win
or not.
Well,
not only that,
like it's not legal.
You have to pretend you're one collar.
Yeah,
you do.
Except the fact that you're in
chocolate body and chocolate face.
What is that?
That's not real.
Is that real?
Just as bill.
He will not believe my face bell mistakes.
I think that might be real.
He went,
leave my face,
bro.
Dude,
he's body.
He went chocolate body.
That not ray.
He was.
He was a really progressive bodybuilder
and he couldn't go blackface.
He went though and then
go back to that picture.
He went chocolate body,
but his face didn't touch it.
You can't give him that much.
Did a little okay.
Give him like he pretended
he rolled around in the dirt.
Can't give him a metal bro.
Yeah,
man.
He's going to win because
he went only chocolate body,
which is totally socially acceptable.
He totally didn't go chocolate
face to chocolate body.
They're literally spray tanning this
people exactly what they're deer and
turning that guy black.
Go back.
Oh my God.
But he keeps the face.
Is this real?
That's before he went out as cannot
be released before he went out.
This is like,
he's like,
you mother fuckers are not taking a
picture of me with black face on within
probably like Michelle,
how ridiculous.
Let's just call it chocolate face.
Let's all call,
but that's just going on
pure chocolate.
I mean,
I know he doesn't want to be racist and
I'm not saying that there's no intent
there to be raising chin.
Imagine.
Imagine if from this conversation,
what the fuck is that guy doing?
That's Brian [inaudible].
Brian,
he's gets his body bronze up to up to
the neck and then he leaves it alone.
What does hats right before I went at him.
Wow.
Okay.
Imagine.
Just imagine if because of
this conversation we put blue,
we bring awareness to chocolate face,
which is essentially a socially
acceptable version of blackface.
We're basically to look at this guy,
you need to go to jail,
sir.
Please
don't tell
me sir.
We give a guy no listen,
but even forget all that.
You don't look better when you do that.
You just look insane like you.
You have a black man's skin
color and you have blonde,
spiky hair.
This is insanity.
What am I looking at?
How hard he worked this way,
dude,
I'm looking at a puzzle.
I'm like,
what is that a hot math?
what is that puzzle?
Oh fuck here with a nice head kick.
Maybe we should pay attention to this.
Awesome fight through that white guy.
Like schooling,
different of chocolate body.
Same Guy.
No,
no,
but that's,
that's one guy dolled up and the other,
just an actual say,
listen man,
I get it.
Black guys look better.
You just going to have to deal
with you see the muscle fiber.
I agreed to just be white chocolate body
body.
I'll read the first one.
Staffer say this.
No,
I'm sure.
I think we might be the first to call it
chocolate body and I think that shit is
going to stick.
Oh,
baffled spending Yeovil by yeah.
You look at it.
Yeah.
You're looking for the sweet.
But think about fighters Tan.
Try to get real tan.
Yeah.
Here keeps the chocolate hip toss.
Yeah,
they do.
Fighters get tanned,
but George Saint Pierre did.
But you know there's a,
there's actually what you got yellow.
It was actually,
there's a,
there's an actual benefit like
in terms of your performance,
the increased vitamin D from getting Tan.
Like,
um,
I think Steve Maxwell told me about this,
that they did some studies,
so get this last position.
These boys are scrapped.
Yeah.
I believe Steve Maxwell
told me that there's a,
there's physical benefits to uh,
getting Tan being out in the sun.
Yeah.
Well not just that,
while you were Tan and your body's jacked
up on vitamin D from the exposure to
the sun,
even I think probably not as good,
but better than nothing.
Exposure to a tanning bed.
That makes sense.
It actually can benefit you.
It's really crazy that
your body makes up vitamin.
I know it's the only way you
can stuff getting sun rays.
Well,
there's other ways to get
it dietarily but you know,
most of the way you get it staring
at the sun or being in the sun.
It is crazy.
Crazy.
How bizarre is that?
God,
I wish one of these two
wind chocolate body.
Yeah.
What?
Imagine if a guy fought in the
UFC chocolate body and he's like,
Bro,
I got to get contracts.
I want to look ripped.
You know,
he couldn't say anything.
I see how guys who are fortunate enough
to have more melanin in their skin,
they look better.
They get more contracts.
It's true.
He can't hold that shit back from me.
Like you remember when Chuck Ladell
used to paint his toenails and then
everybody wanted to paint
their toenails black?
I'm talking about black toes.
Yep.
All we need is one dude to go chocolate
body and everybody goes nuts and he gets
a big endorsement contract.
We need North Carolina triggers
with the fucking beautiful kicks.
But grins Ahmond,
don't give a fuck about your
kicks.
He's such a little monster.
Good defense there by area,
but were Koreans.
Oh,
try it again.
Try it again.
But at the very least it's
allowing him to escape.
Oh,
step in elbow.
Look at that as a creative dude.
Oo.
Oh,
you can clip though.
Temple.
That right hand without the Zombie Dude.
He like you're flashy shit.
And just come forward.
Well in a lot of ways this is a real good
test for him after the Frankie fight.
Good test for both of them,
right?
Yes.
What's matter?
Logo fighters definitely can't do that.
And fake 10 UFC fighter.
Oh Sam Albi did.
Why did he do that?
2015 wow.
You know the UFC had to make in a policy
about putting those fake tattoos on
your back that said like,
uh,
you know,
casino something.com and remember this,
we're doing it.
Yeah.
I think Bernard Hopkins was
the first guy to do that.
There's some guys who did that.
Yeah.
UFC can't do it.
You can't get tattoos,
you know,
that's in your contract.
No tattoos of logos.
Ah,
interesting.
[inaudible] the air it on television.
No basketball too.
Like Jared Smith got like,
I think a supreme tattoo and that they
had to cover it up a large big ass
supreme debt.
Unless you have ownership
in that business.
Don't do that.
Yeah.
What is that about?
I don't know.
He has so many tattoos.
He's probably like,
fuck.
He's like,
come on,
give me a free shit.
That's what he's doing.
Is that what it is?
Wow.
He's got a right off the
back of the sick though.
Oh,
look at that.
Yeah,
you're spinning elbow.
That shit was nasty.
Did you see that replay?
We should pay attention to as far we've
been talking about chocolate bodies.
Yeah.
I think we have a point though,
dude.
I feel like we're the first
ones really call it out.
Yeah.
I've never heard before Jamie.
I don't know.
There's probably a reason why there was
a bunch of them tagged together on a
website.
I'm sure.
True.
I just think it's hilarious when you
see the dudes who don't have chocolate
face,
they chocolate body.
That's so weird looking.
It's just like you like your
face is just a normal color,
but I get it.
I get it.
It does make you look
more defined yet does.
When you're Tan you'd
definitely look more shredded.
Oh Damn.
Yeah.
Here.
But the thing about it is like tanning,
there's not really good for you.
Right?
Like get that dark.
Not all the time.
Right.
If you've got that dark fuck,
they can't do it.
That's why they have to spray paint.
And also I would think that I wouldn't
be mad if Korean Zombie had somewhat of a
Tan,
but whatever.
Oh,
how dare you.
That's what it looks like Bro.
Cause we're creating going
for the sand it up dude.
He does.
It's good head movement too.
He looks,
he looks good.
Standing up dude.
To how fun of a fight would
have been for beat versus Ia.
That's a motherfucking fight.
Yeah.
That would have been really good fight.
I don't like that fight
for as a beat or uh oh man.
Nice right hand by the Korean Zombie.
Well A,
I like it for,
to see entertainment wise.
I want to see what's up.
You know,
it's like a lot of people thought that uh,
Mike Perry had it all day for cowboy and
cowboy just showed everybody what was
up tonight.
That's what's interesting.
Right?
You,
you know,
I want it for a long time.
We know what tub way brings,
we don't know what Mike Perry brings.
We don't know what,
yeah,
you're or fuckings a beat bring.
We don't totally know what they bring,
but we've seen the flyer tested.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we've seen,
yeah,
you're tested against Frankie.
Frankie Edgar just destroyed.
There was even a test that we test
you just like you're not a lot of,
what is this?
What's going on with the left picture?
I can't put that on youtube,
but what is that left
pictures that a guy or girl,
what's a woman?
How come she doesn't have a shirt on a,
she allowed to,
this is the door.
An artist photographer,
a photographer did like a
series of photos on the subject,
dude.
That a transgender,
no,
no.
Son of a bitch.
How dare that's a transgender
woman on the left.
No,
no,
no.
That's a woman who's um,
how shall we put this in a lot of muscle
that was not a woman and the titties
like that.
Those are implants.
No,
it's a woman that's hooked up.
They did the titties or implants.
Right.
But my point is like,
that looks like,
like her body and her proportions
look like that's a man like up
like a different kind of thing.
If that came up to you as a
lady boy and telling him like,
Bro,
the fuck Outta here do better,
but this is what I'm thinking.
She looks like she can be piecing them up.
Is She,
is he,
Oh,
dad's going after him.
Yeah.
She looks like she could be like uh,
a type of human that
evolved on a nearby star.
She looks like Steve Nash with tits.
Am I right?
Like a type of human and evolved in a
nearby galaxy that's super similar to us.
I don't know Bro.
Hopefully not while the,
the implant,
right.
If that wasn't an implant,
if that's just what the breasts look like,
just super muscular on top.
Just like a guy super jacked.
It looks like a rugby player.
And then you get to the titties
and these weird sort of um,
bulbous bags.
Maybe their horns or something.
Hard rocks that they use for chess,
Bang and battle.
God,
I,
that's a tough call jacked.
But that's not a classic female physique,
that's for sure.
I like the nails though.
Long white nails are strong touch.
Go back to that Jamie.
If there was any doubt whatsoever
about the feminine energy.
Yeah,
we them nails powerful.
I'll tell you though,
that's a main demon hands at and David.
Oh full of veins and thick looked like
they'd been just lifting heavy shit for
years.
Jerking off,
dude.
Boom,
boom.
Yeah,
but hey man,
if that's how she wants to look,
I don't give a shit.
Do your thing,
girl.
People that love to get jacked,
they love to just be preposterously.
Whew.
That lady total chocolate face.
How dare you?
That is the most chocolate face.
She's dark chocolate
face to need a new chalk.
Full coke.
She looks damn dude.
If she was on the Meghan Kelly Shelf,
she walked out in the background,
started posing right when Megan
was talking about blackface,
the whole world.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
That's okay.
Hold on.
Okay.
She's a fitness cows or you got your guy.
It's okay bro.
It's a fitness [inaudible]
Olympia next week.
I'm just showing you how rip my face is.
Yeah.
My face is shredded as fuck,
dude.
I'm trying to show off my
jaw muscles right here.
I guess I chew gum all day Bro.
When I want to stop,
I don't of my fucking cheeks or has
wrapped and it just makes zero sense.
My face is chocolate
faces lift for a look at,
oh I have to bro.
Getting that face.
Oh Hey
fella,
you can't do that as an aboriginal
woman in a man's not do that
and someone has to translate the white
man's language too about that is you got
a guy,
why are we giving white
people are looking for gold.
That's exactly like do you have boom,
boom,
go.
Oh how dare you sir.
How many people just want to wear a
black face cause they're super racist and
they can't so they become body builders.
Is that happen dude?
I'm not saying it happens a lot,
but it enough for you.
Has It happened once as one guy but
just to fucking bodybuilder bro.
Man,
get over it man.
man man,
get over it.
Bed.
Yeah,
get over it and he starts like,
oh rapping and shit
dude,
you got
what?
How is that acceptable?
How is that possible?
Oh,
that guy.
It looks like somebody sprayed ANC on him.
Dude.
You know hard.
That shit is to get off to do
these bullshit competition.
That guy looks like,
here's this.
They fell in an oil.
Well,
you know,
unhealthy.
Those people are,
you're the catalyst and it
looks like you fell in oil.
He liked,
they pull them out of an oil.
Well,
I go,
I was in there.
I had a restaurant,
a kid he went under,
he went under and save somebody
and he's a goddamn hero.
And you're,
you don't have to be black.
What's it?
Okay.
Whoa.
That guy might be black.
I think so.
How do you know Jamie don't get
racist on is Jamie Jesus hairs?
Isn't that funny?
That you can get,
that would make you racist.
Like if you thought that one of these
guys in chocolate face and chocolate skin
and chocolate body,
if you thought one of
those guys wasn't doing it,
what the fuck you feel you are racist.
Like,
oh my God,
that's his real color shifts.
It's,
it's more the women do it too though,
right?
Jamie?
It's more of a man thing.
Oh No,
the,
the women do it for sure.
I mean,
I'll see.
Ah Dude.
Oh
Hey,
what are you showing me man?
He keeps it up to the creepy
out look Latina girls.
I just can't man do this.
Round four we talked about this
fight for a total of 20 seconds.
Looks like it's good to
fucking chocolate bodies.
Fucking up the middle by ya here.
Once a Korean zombies forced to
find in the outside like this,
then yeah.
Or his kicks become more dangerous and
that's shit like spinning back fist
because you don't know which,
what's coming.
So he doesn't know where the,
where the distance is,
where he's safe.
It doesn't need to land a real clean
one to stop the Zombie cause he does not
fucking studies the Zombie two.
Nice.
Right hands.
Ooh,
he's,
he's hunted him down.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Oh I think he fell there though.
I definitely fell
filing right now.
Good job chasing after him,
but I think he fell.
Oh Nice Jab.
Damn.
Yeah.
Here's bloodied up.
Yeah,
they're beating each other
up or there's another nice,
nice left hand Korean Zombie.
Switching up from right hand or left hand?
Both fucked up.
Bump their noses look broke.
Yeah,
they're,
they're beat up Korean zombies.
Got some shots with his nose,
but I think with his lip right here.
His upper lip?
Yeah.
Oh,
we just want to build there.
He just threw that punch and a wiggle.
Oh Shit.
He just playing to remember what Korean
Zombie just dipped out for four years to
serve in Korea.
Military have to,
yeah.
It was a few years.
How many years was it?
Was it four?
Four?
He,
I remember he was gone for four years.
Then beat Dennis Bermudez I
think to his lip is fucked up.
I think he kao Dennis Bermudez.
Oh y'all.
You're popped him with the
jab right on that mouth.
I think he's got,
he's got some issues going
on with that upper lip man.
We've seen that before.
Were lip splits.
You seen chocolate?
Dell's when he fought rich Franklin,
that was the worst I've ever
seen is probably the worst.
All right.
Close to four years.
Jamie.
She missed four years.
I think he served too,
but he missed four years in the AFC.
Then came back beat Dennis Bermudez.
What happened?
Korean Zombie just hit
him with a big right hand.
Fuck big right hand.
He's yelling something.
He's saying he's doing something.
He's holding his glove.
He said something through
did it wobble yet.
Yay.
Cracked him.
He cracked him.
Could it was a good shot.
Fucking Zombie man.
Remember his bad ass walk out shirt.
Oh,
he's saying he hit him
in the nuts or is yeah,
you're looking for for a break.
They're not stopping it for that.
I'll come on.
Go Korean Zombie.
Wow.
Let's take no racist.
I don't,
I didn't see that.
Did you see what happened?
Uh,
Zaire was complaining.
They get hit in the nuts
and kept looking at the ref.
What do you see?
What happened that made
him say get hitting them
dude,
but if the ref doesn't stop,
I mean,
come on dude.
They're probably both
exhausts you can see by.
Come on.
Give us a break.
Well,
they're both,
they've taken a lot of palm
trees from Korean Zombie.
Looks like a different person
and so does he.
I hear he's covered in blood.
Oh and right head.
Beautiful left hand.
It looks like one of those
hyenas when they're done,
when they're eating right and they doing
right through a water hogs asshole.
Yes.
Like a fucking water.
Yeah.
Water Buffaloes Dick.
Yes.
Face is all red.
Like some like a waterpik.
Yeah,
some kind of will the beast looking
like a fucking butthole Hyena man.
You see a wart hog?
Yeah,
I've seen a word hung up close.
I don't fucking weird
looking animal that you ever,
you ever watch on,
I forget what the w nature metal.
Where the fuck it is.
We both wanted to go.
Yeah.
Nature's was like a Hyena.
Rick on the fucking water buffaloes to
kick off and it has a sense of material.
I'm like,
I'll watch it five in the morning.
Like God damn it.
It's like a zebra got his fucking air
starched off by a fucking eagle or
something.
James Vick posted something on Instagram
cause you know James Vick has been a
pig hunting lately.
Yeah.
And uh,
he posted this video of a pig eating a
deer and you watch it like a boar wild
pig.
It doesn't necessarily have to be a board,
eat a deer.
It could be a wild female.
So when you think of wild boar,
people think of like a different thing.
Yeah,
that's just a male.
Oh yeah.
So,
but I think,
but a bore isn't the same
as the pig that we eat.
The pink piggies.
They're like dads where it gets strange
because they're actually all the same
species.
Oh Damn.
I did not know that.
They do looks different here for noses.
They're gnarly.
Yup.
They're different in where
they come from to be rocks.
If they're in like Russia,
like Russian bores and the bigger are
all considered among the same genus,
I think they call it.
They say genus.
Is that what you said,
Janice or Gina's?
How do you say that?
Steve or Noah told me all this.
It's an animal species called [inaudible]
and that's what pigs are the same
ladies that you're saying
the eagles different.
Very different.
Because when you leave
pigs out in the wild,
see,
there it is right there.
What are the differences in the border?
Willdabeast while the pigs
called the bore underrated man.
That's just,
yeah,
it says it right here.
It doesn't talk about
the other piece of that.
Uh,
okay.
What does it say?
A wild pig could be called the board,
but that's just the name of it.
Pig.
European wild boar.
Yeah.
Um,
but what are the,
what is,
this is what the question is,
right?
What's the difference between
wild pigs and domesticated pigs?
Pig pig in the w in the more
think a pig is the same family.
It's the same thing.
Oh,
there it is a boy.
Yeah.
An castrated male.
Domestic pig.
That's just the term war.
Uh,
wild boar when I'm asking is,
is a pig in a wild pig,
a domesticated pig in a wild pig?
What's the difference between them?
I don't think there really is.
I think they're the same thing.
It's just they bred one and turned it
into this like real soft sort of thing.
But when they get wild,
their body actually morphs the,
yeah,
they're not pink in the wild.
They get fucked up right now.
They're,
they literally have
changes to their anatomy.
Their nose grows,
their mouth lengthens,
their teeth grow out there,
their hair gets thicker and it
happens just after a few months.
Yeah,
I know what the,
the girls,
there's a wild pig is just both wants to
Twila and then a regular razor back is,
uh,
it's not the answer to my question.
No,
they call it the question is what is
the difference between a wild pig and a
domesticated pig?
Did they have that on there?
Okay.
Google,
what's the difference between a
wild pig versus domesticated pig?
Yeah,
let's see what their piggy,
yeah,
we go a pig hog and board
essentially describe the same animal,
but there are some distinctions,
a bores and uncast
treated male domestic pig.
But it also means a
wild pig of any gender.
A hog off means.
Okay.
If we go deeper into it,
I'm pretty sure that it says that
they're a part of something called Sue
Scrofani.
And Sue's Crawford is the,
uh,
the group that includes wild pigs,
domesticated pigs,
all those different animals.
But when you let them go wild,
they,
uh,
they literally change where they are.
So sue scruff up.
That's it.
So it is kind of the same thing.
It's just they look different
in different places,
but they're the same thing.
Dude.
My son was playing with two baby pigs.
They're eight weeks old.
Got Dan.
They were cute or adorable.
God,
they're cute when you
see them in the wild,
they're so different.
It's such a ruthlessly
aggressive little thing.
Really.
So you want to kill him?
Well,
they're creepy.
They,
I remember the first
time I ever hunted them,
I was with Rinella and we were walking
past this field and the grass was the
brush.
Everything was very thick
and it was really high.
It was like a much
taller than their backs.
So if a pig is,
you know,
like a couple feet tall,
the grass was probably like five,
six feet tall because she
couldn't see where they were.
But you hear him in there
going at it with each other and it's,
dude,
it sounded like there was little demons
in there trying to kill each other.
Then what did you guys just go
in there and mark among this?
They're just,
they're about to throw down.
Look at this like this.
It put their hands up.
What is going on?
Why are they all flat?
Korean Zombie just
looked up at the screen.
Yeah.
He said let's meet right in
the center and throw it out.
I think that's bombies down.
I don't know what happened there.
Zombie looked around like
we're talking about wild pigs.
People like this fucking fight is
amazing and these two assholes,
you a bunch of people to clap and shit.
Chocolate bodies,
chocolate face,
chocolate,
chocolate body's totally okay.
So when you go upstairs
with the face you're,
you're better off going full
white face chocolate body and say,
hey man,
I'll never do black faces disrespectful,
but you have chocolate feet
straight left hand by the Zombie.
That was nice.
Zombies trying to get
in the fucking shootout.
That was a serious straight left.
He's been switching stances and as he
switches stances he pops out left hand in
there.
God,
if someone said,
hey shop,
I'll give you $100,000 tell
me he's winning this fight.
I couldn't do it.
I'm not sure.
I'll tell you about the couple of
things about chocolate bodies and blogs.
I know quite a bit about that.
Let me to,
nothing in a wild pigs.
I know.
It's been an entertaining fight.
Yeah.
Oh,
beautiful.
Spinning back fist.
Yeah.
Here they still,
we that tries to hammer fist.
He's still super creative.
Oh yeah.
He's a fun guy to watch,
man.
I really,
yes.
Oh,
nice.
Right.
We'll shortly,
we'll check.
Hook
that side kick to the knee.
Man.
That's such a nasty move.
Yeah.
Here was that Jackson's for a little bit,
remember?
Yup.
The sidekick is their thing.
Well,
it's a legit move.
Fuck.
Yeah.
That was just good.
Whitaker.
Yoel Romero.
Yeah.
Dude.
How about fucking Weidman can start crazy.
Can you get the next title shot?
Two cranes and,
well,
I guess Aaker ray gets it now.
[inaudible]
style bender with Chuck Gray for,
because Jacqui,
I already lost her Whitaker.
Yeah,
no one wants to see that.
but man,
I mean,
how many more years do you think
geography is going to fight?
He's 38 and I met,
he beat the guy who was
going to get the title shot,
don't you think?
Yeah.
Well,
no.
Weidman was for sure.
They were going to fly him to
the fight to be a alternate.
But here's the thing,
to keep putting their hands up.
There's fucking left.
I don't understand.
Tell you what,
if there's,
what are they doing?
I don't understand.
I too,
if you don't want to get the bonus,
do this kick to the body there.
Oh,
Yolo.
Shift.
Flatline.
Holy.
Holy got seconds left.
Oh,
my
elbow knocked Korean Zombie.
Oh my God.
That was in sick and
kick all the coaches out.
Celebrate the data here is insane.
Flatlined dumb.
Oh my God.
He's Zombie dumb.
He's still out looking at
the doctor over a dire.
Calling the doctor over.
Yeah,
probably knows dude.
That fucking elbow flat.
We had a replay.
Jesus.
Oh,
he's hurt,
man.
Is that he was hurt.
See how he got up and
he just Winston pain.
What do you,
what did he hurt?
Just coach cow.
Here we go.
This is one of the best Naca.
Was that on the Buzzer?
Yes.
Look at this.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Oh,
boring elbow.
Insane.
Holy Fall.
My,
I've never seen a suite like it.
Never ever seen that.
Oh my God.
Oh my goodness.
What a fucking K on a
beautiful elbow credit.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
dude,
that was,
can we get the cliquiness
clock at the bottom?
Oh,
Mike,
two seconds.
Two seconds.
And I wonder what the scorecard we're,
we're going into that.
That's a good question.
I wish we were paying attention
and we watched the Kale.
That's phenomenal,
man.
That is phenomenal.
Look,
it isn't a man Victor Ortiz to Holy Shit.
What a big win for [inaudible].
Victor Davala,
the guy who just jumped in,
use the,
uh,
he's a UFC commentator for the Cortez.
Yeah.
Super good dude.
That's my nails.
Black belts too.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
Him and a ver doom or the deport days,
guys.
Dude,
that right elbow was so nasty.
I've never seen that.
I've never,
ever shot the shot.
Wow.
That is crazy.
That was a,
that was one of the craziest
elbows you're ever going to see,
man.
Best out of the year,
especially considering that
he's got this nickname,
the Korean Zombie,
and we've never seen the,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Was Alster and Francis was that this year?
We're always,
was that this year?
I think this is better.
I've seen how many bright hands connect
that was left fuckings left hook by the
way.
Left right hook.
Technically at the end of
last year was December.
No,
that was the upper cut he had last year.
Last year.
So last year.
So we got this out.
It's out of the running.
That's the number one.
The,
yeah.
Okay.
But Albo from no look fucking right.
But that's,
but that's only you have seen.
Yeah.
Other ones don't really count,
does it?
Or they should.
Well,
okay.
Valid tour
for sure.
Belterra has some good ones.
Okay.
What's the best scale?
Yes.
Pico Santam.
Great Kale.
It goes upper cut that
we talked about earlier.
That upper cuts insane.
I'll flip through here to here
is the best chaos of the year.
Cater.
Yeah.
Kid had had a good one.
I was at that fight.
John Gray Brunson jocker
rate head kicked him.
That's what's so crazy.
Shock race.
Just right here.
Fucking dudes up.
No,
that's,
that's not even the same fucking no,
no,
no.
It's a different thing.
Oh,
fucking Smith.
This is t Santos.
Santos code him though.
But he shot he body shot at
him and then beat him down.
I've never seen a no look
elbow knocking dude out fall.
Um,
if you ever seen Oh yeah.
Meryl rock cold was getting Oh,
Rockhold is fantastic.
Yeah,
it was fucked up.
You Ain't getting that as a beat.
Yeah.
Your fight for some quite some time.
No,
no,
no.
He got fucked up dude.
He is really stand on his leg tube.
When Gol Punches you,
it just seems like a different thing.
The way he punched Rockhold
and then punched him again.
It's like a different thing.
Did you forget 85 there's
some great fucking fire still.
It might be the best division right now.
55 stack.
It is seventies fucking football stats.
The but you know what?
Between Style Bender Bora Cina you know
you got Yoel Romero who's still in the
mix.
Why Robert Whittaker?
Cold Weidman was in that fight.
I know it was good until the last punch.
The jock or array land to the k Odom.
Kelvin Gas Slum Kelvin gasoline there.
Stack rock holds a beast,
man.
Who else?
85 is up there.
How about cannoneer?
Who just fought at 85 looked
like offset first big Wister,
dude,
he looks terrified.
Here it is again.
Oh my goodness.
That is pretty Dick.
Yes.
Look at this slide.
Slide.
Slide Bank.
Ooh.
I mean there's that Lacy
Day is this is placement.
So perfect.
What's he saying about his leg?
He does camp in Cowboy Cerrone
cause they did their camp.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
They just,
uh,
he,
I wonder what happened
to him and he's limping.
Oh,
he's bringing it up now
to break his feet
first round.
He fucked his foot up,
you said.
Okay.
So he kicked his knee accidentally.
He thinks he broke his foot in the first
round or at least fucked his foot up in
the first round.
Wow.
Does he call it the beat now?
Yeah.
Whoever's Sean Shelby and
Dana White want me to fight?
Always a standard thing to say that you
never get picked phase when you do that,
but yeah.
Yeah.
You always get to just go for
someone even it's not your nature.
Yeah.
If you really want that fight,
you got to ask for data and
they put it in their brain.
Otherwise they can give
you what they think's best.
Very interesting fight though for what
we did get to see of it and that elbow
was fucking fantastic.
That's not going to,
yeah,
that's such a really good,
important point about the
difference between recklessly
charging in and you know
what the Korean zombies doing that turning
into a Zombie war like he does every
fight.
It was a work and I feel as,
I feel like you'd probably be up on the
scorecards look like it was working and
then now we'll find out.
We'll find out later what,
what the people that were watching
think even at the scorecards,
one person I've read said he was down
three one going into that round for the
Zombie three rounds to one Zombie was
up from what I saw does not mean the
exchanges looked like it.
He was definitely coming
after him moving forward,
but it looks like GI or was getting
some shots and happy then good for him,
man.
Look if you take the drama too,
there's this family got blood on your mom.
Do we have this again?
This is so sick,
dude.
That's m n one shit.
Ooh,
he just delivered that.
Look at this.
That's radiate.
Oh my God.
One of the best elbow chaos of all AV
or of all times of all time and perfect
time to use that technique.
And that's the number 10 guy in
the world and in the Korean Zombie,
you know,
he's a,
it's a fight where according to
at least one judge he was losing.
That's insane.
And he lands that and it's
just not how the coach,
the bottom line in and it uses
the momentum of his attacker.
Like it's a beautiful lesson in martial
arts for people to watch like a,
when a strike like that lands
and it lands so perfectly,
that opens up that strike
for a lot of people.
100% right.
You remember John Jones started the one
where he touched inside leg and did the
spending and then
everyone started to do it.
Yeah,
no,
John One guy does it.
Yeah.
Did you ever see a gas Tom
Bolano spinning elbow and Beltre.
No Sun dope son.
Really?
You want to see someone look like
they got shot with a laser beam?
Moon really just hits me the head.
That shit.
This dude got hit so hard gas.
Dawn is a,
you know he's a real
worldclass Moy Thai fighter.
Look left.
Oh fuck dude.
Watch this one more time.
Watch this.
Oh my God.
Come on site of them.
But it's the way it lands too.
It's just so perfect.
Ooh.
Now was this against the
number 10 fight in the world?
No.
So yeah,
years is more impressive,
but boom.
I've seen spinning elbows.
Land knocked it down.
That one's pretty cool.
Let's watch it one more time.
Time.
Never seen a guy.
No,
look.
Kao some with an l,
but I don't think I have
either watched it though.
That's real time.
One more time.
Real time.
More time.
Give it to you in real time.
Look at this song that,
I mean,
that is insane.
That's like,
that's the restart.
That's control.
Alt,
delete.
Right to the whole thing
goes dark and comes back up.
Yeah.
But Korean Zombie is a guy who
first of all was deep in that fight.
Maybe even winning that fight,
at least according to one judge known for
being a Zombie known for being able to
take a tremendous shot,
flatline,
toughest shit.
Flatlined flatline and fight.
He might've been winning and powerful.
Rashad here,
shod looking,
suave.
I like your shape to everything.
Whatever.
I like that.
What he's doing his hair.
I liked this purple
psychedelic Paisley tie.
Not Mad at the beard.
I liked the whole look.
Jimmy Smith.
What's that pin?
We think that Penn is so Porsche
pen and I just went to Dick.
You'd be,
if you had like a Ferrari pin.
That's some shit I would do.
I what do you think that Penn is?
I don't know.
It looks like your pores that pin.
Jimmy,
what do you think?
It's probably for veterans today.
Oh,
good call.
Yeah,
keep call doing something
along those lines.
Um,
well dude,
well we covered it all bro.
We could cover it all but fighting
for all you bodybuilders out there.
We don't really care.
No,
keep doing it.
Chocolate bodies.
We actually don't judge it because it's
hilarious and it makes you look better.
You're right dude.
It's an advantage.
Chalk it up bro.
Yeah,
you're right.
I get it.
I get,
I don't think that you
shouldn't be able to do it,
but I do think all of it's crazy.
Now I look at it more.
I don't even think it's racist.
I think they're just trying to
look like they're like a black guy.
Shredded like a black guy,
Dario.
That's exactly what they're doing.
And listen,
it's working for him.
And John Libby's the new
thing highlights credible.
Well definitely has an impact man.
I mean if you're white like paper and
try and look jacked on TV and you're
standing next to a duty when
chocolate face and chocolate Bonnie,
that guy's going to look way darker.
Who wants to be more chocolate?
And the only reason why you should go
chocolate face is because otherwise it's
super distracting.
Cause now you've got to go all
now I don't think you're Tan.
I think you're crazy what's going on.
But do you have like a
suit on like you know,
like a match it,
there's some girls who are particularly
sexually adventurous and they will,
uh,
even for Halloween parties
we'll just paint their tits.
Yes.
That was the thing that
was going on for a while.
It was crazy like crazy.
It was like a loop.
Crazy hot,
crazy hot.
But it was like a loophole where girls
could basically be topless at parties
with paint on her tits.
You could see their full nipple,
but it was all heated stars over there.
Areolas are you watching twitch
these days while it's still going on?
What's twitch?
What's going on?
What's going on in twitch?
I don't know what day
they changed the rules,
but the rules got changed sometime.
Why they changed the rules?
No,
the other way to let
them paint their tits.
Why not listen?
If you can wear like some shear skin tight
shirt that shows your nipples and I'm
all for that.
Why can't a girl painter
tits and make some money?
What do you want to work at Denny's
motherfucker to guy pain his dick and make
some money?
Yes.
Okay.
That's what I'm talking about.
Perfect.
Too Hot.
This girl just has her
titties all done up scraping.
Only this one.
This is twitch world.
Yeah,
so they have fake Becu.
Get on Twitter.
It's just titties.
She has some tiny dude,
this is naked.
This girl's got no,
stop it.
You asshole.
The girls.
These girls separate them.
Oh,
but this is the LLC,
the dark web now.
No,
no,
no.
We're good.
Leave it alone.
The point is they're allowed to do it.
She's got barbs through those nipples.
What's happening down there?
Hey man,
is there something happening
onto those nipples?
Am I just looking at it right?
This is twitch.
What the fuck did they do it for?
What are those things on her nipples?
Are those,
is that some sort of a,
an object?
Yeah.
What does that sound like?
A nail through it.
Oh,
was that paint?
That's the way.
It's all pain.
I thought maybe she had some sort of
ring going on and I talk about twitch,
like my dad asking me
about CBD will ever know.
I have no clue.
I couldn't tell you what people do.
A lot of shows on twitch now.
I know a lot of,
uh,
you know who contacted me the other day,
Bubba the love sponge.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He's doing a show on twitch.
He does a show on twitch.
Like a straight,
what do you mean show?
He was a famous a radio guy and still is.
I mean,
did,
uh,
he used to be on Sirius in the early
days when Howard first got public.
Loves Punch was on a show like this.
On twitch?
Yeah,
apparently.
Yeah.
On twitch yet p I think jeans and,
and [inaudible] are doing
it on their mom's house.
Tom and Christina,
other hip,
they're cool.
They're doing,
they're doing twitch as well.
Have you looked into it?
Jamie?
Myself,
but I play video games,
but it's expanded over the last,
I don't know,
a year to two more than video games.
There's podcast sections,
there's music sections.
They tried to do like a comedy section.
Even they're trying to entice people
to do stand up comedy on there.
Yeah,
it's a terrible idea,
but that doesn't work.
But there's tons,
there's tons more than
just video games on there.
Now.
When people first started doing podcasts.
One guy asked me to do as podcasts
and then asked me to do stand up.
They do it the live podcasts he wanted
me to do stand up on the podcast.
I go,
what are you talking about?
do you want me to do
my act on your show to,
and then it just gets
released on the Internet.
I just do it that way.
Instead of just getting
paid for comedy central,
Netflix special,
like what are you talking about it?
Why would they do that?
And you just,
and you're just going to sell it.
No idea.
He just going to sell this
podcast to put it out and well,
how much do I get out of this?
Zero.
Okay,
that sounds like a good deal.
My materials out there,
but that was early days of podcasting.
He was trying to figure out
what the hell it was like,
what is this thing?
It's hilarious.
This,
it's just a joke.
Is Anybody paying attention?
Who's watching?
Little did they know?
Yeah.
It's just,
uh,
I remember Kevin Smith was one of the
first guys who take it seriously because
he rented a theater.
He had a theater on Melrose.
It was like,
um,
the smog cast theater and uh,
we used it once.
I used it once,
the interview
was it Tom Green and Jim Norton,
I think I did two podcasts there.
I did one with Tom Green
and one with Jim Norton.
Yeah.
It was interesting.
It was cool.
It's different.
It's interesting,
but it's different.
Yeah.
Doing it live in front of
an audience is different.
It's not like,
do you guys still do live fighter
and the kid shows we don't,
he don't know.
Too busy with both of your standup.
Too busy.
Yeah.
Rare.
Brian,
I get together live show.
I guess that's good because
it means you're both busy.
Cause that's exactly the same thing
that happened like me and Joey and uh,
and even me when me and
Ari and me and Dunkin,
it's like everybody else just got too big.
You know,
Ari's just headline
these giant ass places.
Now when Joey's headline and giant ass
places and you know [inaudible] selling
out everything all across the country.
Yeah.
It's just how it goes.
You know,
if you're,
you're doing stuff with people,
eventually they wind up doing
something else and you know,
I know you,
you are doing really well
with your standup comedy.
It's probably hard to do.
Those shows still shows
her a different thing.
Right.
It takes away from what I'm doing,
you know,
like the original goal,
like if I'm going to
dedicate time and stage,
it's going to be to my right.
Especially because you kind of have to,
if you want a headline,
places keep pumping out new shit
and you want to do a special,
as much as fun as that
have with the lifeline,
the kids,
it was the exact opposite.
Like,
no,
it was just improv and me and Brian
Dicken Ram was the time we can,
I can better than anything
at the time with your buddy,
right?
You're not making your,
your act stronger.
Piecing up your materials.
I read the last one.
I told Brian this what me and
him did one at the comedy store.
I don't know,
like a year at least ago.
Year and a half maybe we got done.
I was like,
I'm done with these dude.
Wow.
Oh,
you had a weird one,
right?
It was one of them that came
out weird at the comedy store.
It's just wasn't weird bookie.
He was clunky.
Yeah.
Cause we haven't been together
a while and we did that.
I'm like,
dude,
this isn't the best product for you or me.
Right.
It makes us look bad.
I feel like I can write.
I think you got to respect what that is.
If we're going to do like a two man show,
he got to coordinate the shit out
of that requires a lot of work.
Can't wing it.
Especially from people going
from pain to see you do stand up.
They see your standard back,
which is,
you know what it is.
They go from seeing that to that.
I felt like it was hurting
the brand or anything.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
I think Brian agreed to and that,
you know,
but like we did a show together
with Ari and big J and that,
that was fun.
That was fine.
That was a,
there was a,
all things comedy.
They're doing a festival down there.
US brought us all in all things comedy.
He's doing a lot of shit,
man.
They're killing it.
They're doing specials.
Yeah,
they can do,
they're doing Ian Edwards special.
Are they really?
That's dope.
Oh,
Yay.
Comedy central game especially.
But there's something with
that and like Ari Feo,
Brian Big Jay and I were
all talking about like,
we could do the same way.
Um,
frickin they did the white comedy tour.
Blue was at plu coming
toward white coming here.
Where the fuck it was.
You could do,
we could do that once a month.
Just pick one city dude.
Like two big ass shows and get out.
Yeah.
But dude,
like announced a tour with it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
It'd be fun.
You know,
and also like you're
doing comedy clubs too,
which is so important at this stage of
like when you're trying to ramp up to a
special in January,
you've got to do a lot of comedy clubs
because you get those to show at nights
and two shows.
Friday two shows.
Saturday one Thursday tooth
to Friday to Saturday.
If that's good.
Thursday's a warmup set.
Yes.
Get things and get that bitch hot.
Yeah.
Ooh,
come in guns blazing on Friday.
I tell you what's weird to to,
to relate it to fighting is
that I was like go fuck him.
I'm about nine weeks out from the special.
It almost feels like you're like,
damn you gotta I dunno.
I think you know,
he say that Louis C K he used
to treat it like it was a fight.
You'd go running and get in shape
and run like five miles a day.
He'd be like ramp up like actual physical
training to prepare for comedy special
10 my Diet's,
I'm sweating now,
my diet and my workouts.
Well,
what I learned from this sober October,
a workout challenge,
fitness challenges that Ari and Tom and
Burt and I did was that when you work
out a lot like that,
you do a shit ton of cardio.
You don't give a fuck.
You're anxiety is severely,
severely diminished.
You feel so good.
It's crazy when you do a lot cardio
like I was doing on a normal
day at any average day,
I might be working out three
and a half hour too much.
That's crazy.
Crazy too much,
but it was just for a month,
but the point was that,
and I don't think you need
to do three and a half hours,
but you might need to do an hour.
If you can do an hour of hard cardio,
you don't give a fuck.
That's what I tried to do.
Shell 60 minutes of
hard where I'm burning.
Yeah,
800,000 calories.
That's all you have to do.
That's it.
Yeah.
Dude,
I fee.
I feel really good when
I work out like that.
If I don't,
I feel like my demeanor,
I'm not as fun.
I'm now creative,
like I don't feel great too though,
saying that if it was a pill,
if you give someone a pill and that pill
could make me feel like I feel after I
work out for three and a
half hours addicted to it,
I would take that pill every day.
That's some,
I don't give a fuck juice
called Oxycontin Joe.
But what it,
no,
it doesn't change who you are.
Like if you get a spelling bee,
I fuck up the same words account the same.
And that was the thing was interesting.
Like I was worried it was going to
negatively affect my podcast because I was
worried that I'd be too tired.
I come in here,
I'd just be ragdoll and beaten down,
but I wasn't,
you shed more than energy.
Right.
And a lot of energy.
Like Jamie,
I didn't seem like any slower or anything,
did I?
You know,
it fucks me up and we've
talked about this before.
What's that?
Fucking yoga classes too.
And I do a 90 minute yoga
class and I come in here,
I am way more fucked up.
Fuck yeah.
Because that mental energy with that,
it's not just that,
it's like what you're,
what you're doing to elevate your heart
rate is so much more exhausting to your
muscles than say running for cause
you can't hold the yoga path.
A yoga pose for as long as you can run,
you can run like for
hours and you've been,
you're not,
you're not doing and you're going left,
right,
left,
right.
It's just like this steady push,
relax,
push,
relaxing your,
your,
your legs have like a half a
second to recover with each step.
That's what's going on.
But it's different because yoga,
you could never do that.
Like when you're in a yoga pose,
like you're in,
um,
you know,
triangle pose or something like that.
How long can you hold that Hoodie?
Keep Ahold of it minute.
Can you hold it?
Five minutes.
Maybe you're in fucking tremendous shape
and you could do the bow pose where you
hold your foot and you put it
over behind you and you have,
maybe you could do that for five
minutes if you were in fucking Chad.
Tremendous,
tremendous shape.
But damn,
that is hard to do.
What does that Jamie scorecards,
everyone had Korean Zombie up.
Yeah.
Set for one gut sit for one judge
or one judge had even going in.
Other judges had green on every card.
Mm.
So someone at two,
two others at three.
One three,
one three,
one,
two,
two.
Interesting.
What a KL.
What Amazing Cook Kale.
All right.
All right,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Everybody out there being
affected by the fires.
We genuinely and sincerely hope
you and your family are safe.
Uh,
it's,
it sucks if you lose your place,
but you know,
it's way worse if you're dead.
Um,
what's positive is your friends and
your family and your loved ones.
And that means a lot to me right now.
So I'm thinking about it even
though I'm evacuated and uh,
I'm sure,
uh,
I know,
I already know people that for
sure have lost their houses,
but uh,
we'd feel a whole lot worse.
We lost them,
you know,
it's hard to deal with.
It's rough.
It's not a good thing,
but it's also a humbling reminder of
where we are and that nature is a thing to
be respected and feared.
And when fire gets out of hand,
there's some serious fucking consequences
and I don't know what solutions there
are to fixing something like this,
but I think if there was a an invading
army that came here and did the kind of
damage and devastation that
these forest fires have done,
there would be some serious steps
to protect us against that army.
If there is a profit to be
made and figuring out how
to protect people from this
kind of fucking horrendous fire like
well I don't know what it would be.
I don't know what would be hiring way
more firefighters or putting way more
precautions in place or,
or hiring people and Donald Trump creating
new jobs to clear all this dead wood
and the in the forest and,
and to figure out some way to get to the
scene quicker and have flights that are
ready on standby filled
with water at all times.
I don't know what the fuck it would be,
but it seems to me that these things
when they get out of hand like this,
leave people unusually helpless.
Like we're oftentimes help us to nature.
This is,
this is one of those unusually helpless
moments where it makes you really
understand how dangerous fire is and,
uh,
nothing but love and respect out there
for all the firefighters and first
responders and all these people
that are taking care of people.
And,
and shout out to Whitney coming,
saving animals are girls
out there in Malibu.
Save an animals,
bringing them to shelter.
She saved horses,
chickens and shit.
She likes channels people.
Yeah,
she's always been an animal person.
Pov.
Whitney Cummings.
All right.
Thank you to you all much love.
Bye.